Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Wo sind wir hier? Man hört's grummeln, glaube ich.
Wir sind in der Filmwerkstatt in Düsseldorf. Und wir sitzen hier, unterhalten uns ganz leise, denn wir sitzen bereits auf der Bühne und vor uns sitzt das Publikum und in zehn Minuten geht es los. Wir sprechen hier auf Einladung über KI. Was hast du mitgebracht?
Wir feuern heute Clips ab von Markus Gabriel und Christian Uhle. Beide im Kontrast. Wir haben ja hier auch das Subthema Latenz. Und beide reden über KI und Gefühle. Und Gefühle sind ja laut Peter Fuchs das Unaussprechbare, das man dann gerade noch mit Gefühlslabels markiert, um zu sagen, übrigens, hier gibt es unaussprechbares Gefühle. Damit holt man sich auch ein bisschen Reflektionssperre rein. Man muss dann gar nicht so viel erklären. Man sagt einfach, ich habe Gefühle und alle so, ah ja, okay, ich nehme deine Angst, deine Wut, deine Liebe ganz ernst und das kontrastieren wir heute. Denn der eine unterwirft sich Gott und gibt die Menschheit verloren. Der andere sagt, wir können jetzt mal Arbeit neu organisieren und vielleicht den ein oder anderen Befreiungsschlag dank KI jetzt nutzen.
Die Zukunft gestalten.
Genau, wir können jetzt schon mal überlegen, wer von beiden.
Ja, ich überlege gerade, wer könnte es sein. Ja, ich habe Clips dabei von Adam Tooze. Wir wollen das nämlich auch auf eine ökonomische Grundlage stellen. Denn die Frage ist ja, was passiert, wenn es eine Blase ist und was ist, wenn es keine Blase ist? Und beide Antworten sind vielleicht ein bisschen besorgniserregend. Wir sollen ja hier auch, denn das ist ja im Rahmen einer Tagung veranstaltet worden, dieser Live-Podcast am Abend über Latenz und latente Räume sprechen. Deshalb habe ich auch ein paar Clips von Elena Esposito dabei, die sich ja mit maschinellem Lernen und der maschinellen Sprache auseinandergesetzt hat. Da ein paar Punkte, warum das eben doch sehr anders ist bei der KI als bei Menschen. Und obwohl das so ist, können wir trotzdem kommunizieren oder vielleicht brauchen wir auch gar nicht das Verständnis des anderen. Also wir sind da bei dem Begriff der doppelten Kontingenz und sind dann auch vielleicht schon sehr schnell bei der Latenz angekommen. Also was für Räume eröffnen sich da? Vielleicht Illusionsräume oder sonst etwas, wenn wir etwas eingeben in die KI. Die weiß nicht, was wir da eigentlich wollen. Wir wissen nicht genau, gibt es so etwas wie ein Willen bei der KI? Was spuckt sie uns aber dann am Ende aus? Und was machen wir damit? Beziehungsweise ist ja auch die Frage, wenn derart spekuliert wird darauf, dass die künstliche Intelligenz vielleicht sogar übermächtig wird. Was schwingt da eigentlich die ganze Zeit mit, was nicht so klar präsent ist, aber doch anwesend ist in irgendeiner Weise?
Simulation, Spiel und Spekulation.
Ja.
Alle drei großen Themen kommen heute bei uns vor.
Gut. Und wer das hören mag, kommt einfach in den Salon. Das ist möglich über Patreon, Apple und wir empfehlen es besonders Steady. Man geht auf die Seite neu20er.de. Dort kommt man dann direkt zu Steady, hat dann nicht nur Zugang, wenn man ein Abo abschließt zu diesem Live-Salon, sondern zu allen Live-Salons und zu allen regulären Salons. Wir sprechen ja im Dezember noch über Branko Milanovic's Buch im regulären Salon. Und wir haben ja noch mal einen Live-Salon im Dezember, kurz vor Weihnachten, dann traditionell in der Käs. Bis dahin.
Viel Spaß nun und für Salonmitglieder gilt, ihr kriegt es bis zum Schluss.
Guten Abend, Düsseldorf.
Wir sind also zu euch gepaaren. Wir sind die einzigen Nicht-NRWler hier im Raum, haben wir gerade festgestellt. Und da es heute Abend ein Thema gibt, Latenz, müssen wir es kurz thematisieren. Wir stehen alle noch unter dem Eindruck, dass wir den Techniker gerade ins Schwitzen gebracht haben, weil ein Brummen zu hören war, für das wir verantwortlich sind und nicht die Haustechnik. Das wird aber jetzt, kriegt es einen grünen Haken. Wir haben es jetzt abgeschlossen, wir hoffen es kommt nicht wieder und können jetzt in unser Thema starten.
Das heißt, wir stehen der Technik doch immer wieder gegenüber und wissen eigentlich nicht, was zu tun ist.
Ja, so ist es. Sie ist unberechenbar, wir kriegen sie überhaupt nicht gebändigt.
Nein, das ja nicht, wie wir noch heute Abend erfahren werden. Aber vielleicht geben wir kurz den Kontext für diejenigen, die jetzt hier sind oder uns zuhören. Es ist so, dass hier eine Tagung stattfindet zum Thema Latent Space, Latente Räume. Es gibt eine Filmreihe, die durfte ich kuratieren. Dort gibt es zu sehen zum Thema Latent Arrival, Cachet von Michael Hannecke, hast du vielleicht gesehen, dann von Claude Sauté, Die Dinge des Lebens und das ist schon am Donnerstag gezeigt worden, Marlene, ein Dokumentarfilm von Maximilian Schell über Marlene Dietrich aus dem Jahr 1981. Ich will dir nur ganz kurz davon erzählen, denn es ist ja so, dass Marlene Dietrich sich 1975 zurückgezogen hat aus der Öffentlichkeit und sagt, die Legende muss weiterleben, das bedeutet aber, mein biologischer Körper muss versteckt werden vor der Öffentlichkeit. Also blieb sie in diesem Pariser Apartment, ließ sich nicht mehr fotografieren oder filmen, aber Maximilian Schell hat sie überredet zu einem sechstägigen Interview und aus diesen Tonbandaufnahmen hat er dann einen Film kollagiert. Das Besondere nun daran ist aber, dass wir permanent Kommunikation scheitern sehen, weil Maximilian Schell gerne mit Marlene Dietrich über ihr Verb sprechen möchte und Interpretationen vorschlägt und all das. Und Marlene Dietrich machte eine Totalverweigerung, sagte eigentlich zu jedem Satz, weil das ist ja Quatsch, also ich bitte Sie und nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Nur in dieser Art kommuniziert sie. Also das ist so fehlende Kommunikation. Und es gibt eine sehr schöne Aussage von Maximilian Schell, dann später im Spiegel, dann sagte er, sie wusste nicht, was ich von ihr wollte. Und ich wusste es aber auch nicht so richtig. Und da sind wir doch eigentlich schon mitten an unserem Thema der Latenz. Und wie kommunizieren wir eigentlich mit den intelligenten Maschinen?
Und gab es denn in dem Film einen Mehrwert, den man unscheinbar, unsichtbar, wie auch immer, hätte lassen müssen, wenn sie eine Dampfplauderin gewesen wäre?
Nein, es geht nur so. Also nur deshalb hat der Film den Mehrwert, weil die Kommunikation die ganze Zeit scheitert. Weil wir hier das erfahren, wie Filme gemacht werden. Nämlich es gibt Intentionen. Aber das müssen nicht die Intentionen sein, die uns zu interessieren haben. Wir sehen auch da was über Textbildschere. Also man kann sich mal das bei YouTube ansehen. Leider gibt es den Film nirgends verfügbar. Aber man kann sich mal bei YouTube ansehen, wie Marlene Dietrich dann schon mit 70 und älter singt den Song Johnny, wenn du Geburtsdag hast. Und dann kann man mal beobachten, wie sie das Mikrofon so betastet. Und die Assoziationen sind sehr naheliegend, was da eigentlich versinnbildlicht wird. Und wir hören aber jetzt in dem Interview Marlene Dietrich die ganze, wir hatten ja von der Erotik keine Ahnung, wussten ja gar nicht, was wir da tun. Also sie versucht die ganze Zeit zu verweigern, dass da irgendeine Intention war. Und wenn sie auch vielleicht nicht da war, auf uns wirkt es natürlich trotzdem, dass uns klar ist, was hier erotisch evoziert werden soll. Und damit können wir wieder einmal sehen, dass wir nicht in die Köpfe derjenigen hineinblicken können, mit denen wir sprechen. Und wir können ja auch nicht genau wissen, was die KI jetzt gerade so macht. Aber sie gibt eine Antwort. Und vielleicht gelingt die Kommunikation besser als bei Max Schelle und Marlene.
Also, latente Räume ist ja ein sehr mutiger Themeinschlag. Aber hier kann man es sehen, denn offenbar ist der latente Raum die Vergangenheit, in der Sachen entschwunden sind und damit fast unwiederbringbar verloren. Aber die gute Erinnerung, wir haben ja ein ausreichend großes Tokenfenster, um so zu sagen. Wir wissen dann nochmal, was uns der Schäl eigentlich zeigen wollte. Und dann findet Kopfkino statt. Auch ein latenter Raum, Kopfkino. Kann man später darauf zu sprechen.
Wir sollten erstmal uns auf eine ökonomische Grundlage begeben, wenn wir über KI sprechen, über den KI-Hype. Und deswegen dachte ich mir, nehmen wir einen alten Bekannten, Adam Tooze, der hat ja auch einen Podcast für das Surplus-Magazin, wird dort auch zu KI befragt und sagt Folgendes.
Das Versprechen, und man muss es ja auch so formulieren, das Versprechen der Befürworter von KI ist, dass sie den allergrößten Teil der einigermaßen routinemäßigen Büroarbeit, alle Steuerungsfunktionen im Grunde automatisieren können und damit Menschen ersetzen können. Das heißt also, die Schätzungen gehen bis zu einigen 100 Millionen Arbeitsplätzen, die sofort berührt werden davon, 40 Prozent der Arbeitskraft, alles von, sagen wir mal, großen Teilen der juristischen Arbeit, die natürlich in einem riesigen Sektor privatwirtschaftlich organisiert ist, und alles von Routine juristischer Arbeit bis hin zum natürlich zum Taxifahren. Wir haben es ja bereits gesehen, du kannst gewiefte langjährige Taxifahrer durch migrantische Überfahrer ersetzen. Sie müssen die Stadt überhaupt nicht kennen. Sie folgen einfach nur das Algo. Das ist KI in Aktion.
Ja, wir saßen gestern beim Schnitzel nach unserem Podcast und haben auch darüber geredet. Ich natürlich überambitioniert gesagt, zwei Milliarden Bullshit-Jobs fallen alle weg. Dann habe ich heute Morgen den Doppelgänger-Podcast gehört, in dem noch mal eine ganz tolle argumentative Wendung kam, nämlich man muss das ja, also wenn man es jetzt in zwei Schritten sieht, kann man KI einsetzen, wo heute Menschen beschäftigt sind. So, das ist typischerweise ein Schritt. Und die Doppelgänger haben dann folgendes Szenario gemacht. Wir können ja erst mal nur die Bullshit-Jobs streichen, uns dann den ökonomischen Effekt ansehen und dann die KI einbauen. Und es könnte nämlich sein, dass man schon beim ersten Schritt alleine feststellt, ah nee, brauchen wir gar nicht. Also, dass das Menschliche durch nichts ersetzt wird, ohne dass er sich in Bilanzen niederschlägt.
Das ist ja etwas, was wir auch schon in den vergangenen zwei Jahren immer wieder erlebt haben. Es gab ja Unternehmen, die sich von vielen Mitarbeitern getrennt haben bzw. die sie dann entlassen haben. Und dann sagten sie häufig, wir setzen jetzt voll auf KI. Wenn man dann nachschaute, dann stimmte das oft gar nicht. Sie haben einfach noch gar nicht auf KI gesetzt, aber haben schon einmal Entlassungen durchgeführt, weil sie sich tatsächlich gefragt haben, ob gewisse Bullshit-Jobs noch gebraucht werden oder geht das nicht auch in schlankerer Form. Da sind wir natürlich in einem Bereich, wo man sagen kann, wann wird es ineffizient bzw. welches Unternehmen entsteht dann daraus. Denn damit ist ja auch, da waren wir noch gar nicht im KI-Hype, Elon Musk angetreten, als er Twitter gekauft hat und zu ex umgewandelt hat. Da hat er sich ja auch gerühmt, ich bin derjenige, der ganz viele rauswerfen kann und trotzdem wird dieses Unternehmen so wunderbar funktionieren.
Genau. Also Twitter ist heute in der Belegschaft 80 Prozent kleiner. Ist quasi nur noch so ein Rumpf übrig und könnte sein, dass es demnächst wirklich nur noch GROG ist, dass so ein bisschen KI reinsteuert.
Allerdings ist jetzt auch nicht besser geworden die Plattform.
Genau, das möchte ich sagen. Das sieht man auch.
Ja, ja, das ist der Punkt, wie weit das dann geht. Aber das ist ja erst mal so eine Diagnose, die Tuzi aufstellt, die jetzt nicht besonders neu ist für uns. Wir haben ja alle schon mal darüber so nachgedacht. Dann gäbe es noch den Bereich der Kunst oder der Creative Industries, der anzusprechen wäre, was kann also da die KI bald machen? Da, denke ich, erleben wir natürlich in Hollywood und sonst wo eine Disruption, gerade bei den Leuten, die die Bilder bearbeiten. Wir haben ja ohnehin schon gemerkt, dass selbst viele teure Blockbuster immer schlechter gemacht waren, also die Effekte mitunter. Deshalb, weil man das outgesourct hat, weil man das irgendwo zusammenklöppeln ließ und entsprechend waren dann auch manchmal das Ergebnis. Nun versucht man selbstredend, so auch der Sohn von Alison, dass man mit der KI sehr viel Arbeit einsparen kann. Ich glaube, wir haben uns in dieser Debatte aber so sehr, wenn es um die kreativen Industrien geht oder die Kulturindustrie geht, darauf versteift, dass wir über die Künstler sprechen. Drehbuchautoren waren ganz groß im Gespräch. Da würde ich sagen, hat es keinen großen Effekt, wenn man dort auf KI setzen würde. Man muss ja gucken, wo ist Einsparpotenzial. Man kann, wenn man zwei, drei Drehbuchautoren wegspart, die man braucht für die Serie, nicht wirklich viel Geld sparen. Das ist nicht der Fall. Es muss wirklich darum gehen, wenn es jetzt im Effizienzgedanken ist, zu sagen, wie werden wir 300 Leute los? Warum kostet der Blockbuster 300 Millionen? Kann der nicht auch 100 Millionen kosten? Da ist natürlich dann die Frage, wie viele Menschen braucht man dafür? Das ist sicherlich etwas, was wir da erleben werden, was aber auch bedeutet, dass wir vermutlich den Versuch serviert bekommen, dass wir uns an schlechtere Bilder gewöhnen, was ja auch gut sein kann.
Aber das wird ja eh unterschätzt. Der Mensch wird eh immer ein bisschen überschätzt. Wenn man sich so einen 400 Meter langen ICE anschaut, der hat einen Zugführer, der sitzt vorne drin und hat einen Hebel. Der Rest sind 20 Leute, die halt ein bisschen Service machen und auf Sicherheit achten. Die wegzusparen, ist ja in der Gesamtrechnung dann auch. Also macht ja kein Kraut mehr Fett, fällt gar nicht auf, würde ich fast sagen. Bisschen mehr Verwaltung noch für die Zugbegleitung sozusagen vor Ort, die dann im Büroturm stattfindet. Aber das wird ja sowieso niemand sehen, wenn sich das verändert. Also in der Ansicht ist eh immer schon weiter geht.
Das heißt aber, wir sind hier in einem Bereich, wo wir dann nicht über die Originalität sprechen. Denn das ist ja das, was die KI dann nicht liefert. Die liefert nicht das sehr gute Drehbuch. Da sind wir weiterhin auf menschliche Autoren angewiesen, wenngleich ja auch Menschen viel Mist fabrizieren können. Ich habe ja jetzt gerade den neuen Matthias Schleichl verfilmt gesehen. Ich kann dir sagen, das hätte vielleicht dein Gemini oder dein Clot besser gekonnt. Aber es ist ja dennoch so, dass wir sagen, hier sehen wir auch bei dem Rezipienten direkten Bezug zum Namen. Also wir wollen ja nicht KI-Schauspieler haben. Ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, dass sich das durchsetzen wird. Man wird diese Experimente machen, aber dass da eine Bindung zu aufgebaut wird. Denn die Bindung ist ja jetzt auch schon eine Irrationale. Das wird ja so häufig vergessen. Man hat diese Hollywood-Stars, aber sie sind ja nicht in dieser Position, weil man sagt, das sind die Einzigen, die die Rolle spielen können. Ich bin mir sicher, im Düsseldorfer Schauspielhaus sind ähnlich gut ausgebildete Schauspieler, die ähnlich die Rollen spielen könnten. Wir haben nur diese Bindung zu einem Star.
Ich will auch immer Brad Pitt sehen und Tom Cruise.
Ja, das ist sicherlich auch ein Problem. Ich glaube an unserem Kino, dass alle immer nur noch die Alten sehen wollen und die müssen dann immer jetzt Rennfahrer mit über 60 spielen. Da weiß man eigentlich, geht das nicht so richtig zusammen außer auf der Kö. Da fahren auch ganz viele Herren über 60 mit sehr dicken Autos rum.
Ja, solange die KI dafür sorgt, dass Brad Pitt trotz 61 oder 62 Jahre aussieht wie 40.
Ich glaube, man sagt nicht dringend dazu, ja. Aber es gibt ja noch eine dritte Dimension. Also neben dem, sagen wir, juristischen, administrativen Apparat und dem künstlerischen Apparat, gibt es ja noch eine dritte Dimension, ohne auf die Come To's zu sprechen.
Also das heißt, was heißt, die Entwicklung von Pharmazeutika oder die Entwicklung von CHEPS oder die Entwicklung von neuen Hochtechnologien und dass das potenziert werden kann. Und wenn das gelingt, dann ist das, sagen wir mal makroökonomisch gesehen, der größte Wachstumstreiber aller Zeiten. Denn die Wirtschaftstheorie ist ja sich in einem Punkt mindestens einig, dass im Grunde dieser unerklärbaren technologischen Fortschritt alles erklärt ist. Das heißt, es ist eine schwarze Kiste, da ist alles drin. Und daraus sprudelt dann halben die neuen Sachen. Und wenn wir jetzt durch Investitionen im KI die abnehmenden Grenzerträge im Forschungsbereich überwinden können, die sich ja bemerkbar machen, man steckt mehr und mehr Geld in die Forschung, man kriegt weniger Patente raus, vor allem weniger gute Patente, wenn man jetzt durch KI in die Lage versetzt wird, wirklich fundamentale Probleme zu cracken, dann erschließen sich Möglichkeiten, mit einer Geschwindigkeit und einer Radikalität, wie wir es bisher erlebt haben.
Das war mir auch noch nicht klar, dass es zwar unglaublich viele Patente gibt, aber dass sie offenbar nicht mehr so einen großen Effekt haben. Wir haben ja schon mal über Wachstumsschwäche, die systeminherent ist, gesprochen. Wir haben schon mal über so eine Frage der Überkapazitäten und all das gesprochen, aber dass man sagen kann, momentan gibt es zwar viele Patente, neue Patente, aber sie sind offenbar nicht so gut und gut meint ja jetzt hier verwertbar, sind nicht auf eine Verwertbarkeit hinausgelegt in einer Weise, dass man sagen kann, damit steigert man jetzt noch mal erheblich das BEP.
Ja, wer weiß. Keine Ahnung. Also ist scheiß mir ein Werturteil zu sein. Ich sehe jedenfalls klinische Forschung und Studien zum Thema Krebs, was es vorher nicht gab.
Hier ist ja nur die Frage, wächst da durch BEP, nicht kann man damit Krankheiten heilen. Und das scheint ja offenbar eine gewisse Stagnation dort eingetreten zu sein, wie Tuze diagnostiziert. Die Erwartung ist jetzt mit KI folgende.
Das sind dann die wirklich entfesselten Fantasien, wo dann auf einmal innerhalb der nächsten paar Jahre die amerikanische Wirtschaft auf eine Wachstumsrate von 7 oder 8 Prozent springt. Und dann sieht natürlich die gesamte Welt anders aus. Und wenn du daran glaubst, und es gibt ja wirklich Leute, die das mit Haut und Haaren jeder Hinsicht in den Poren ihres Körpers glauben, dass sie wirklich diese Revolution mitbauen, dann gibt es natürlich nichts anderes.
Wir haben jetzt Mark Zuckerberg, der gesagt hat, dass sie 100 Milliarden im nächsten Jahr investieren. Das ist also einmal ein Sondervermögen. Das wird investiert. Und man geht da zu...
20 Frankfurter Skylines.
50 Milliarden könnten für Chips ausgegeben werden. Und möglicherweise wirken diese Chips dann nicht, die von NVIDIA sein.
Also da bin ich auch mal sehr gespannt. Denn jetzt, wo mein liebes Claude auf TPUs von Google trainiert wird und der Markt erstrocken feststellt, ach so, die ganze Grundlagenforschung und die ganzen Patente liegen bei Google dafür. Und im Vergleich zu so einer GPU von NVIDIA ist auch nochmal 40 Prozent Energiesparung möglich.
Und das war ja nicht jetzt, also TPU ist ja eben nicht, einfach Graphic Prozessors, also viel enger schon auf KI ausgerückt.
Genau, das ist ja wirklich auf die Tenso, ganze Rechenproblematik optimiert. Und wir haben jetzt 5 Billionen Unternehmenswert für NVIDIA. Und ich glaube, 4,5 Billionen davon sind einfach getriebener, Medien halb so.
Das ist eine kühne Behauptung. Wir geben ja hier keine Anlagetipps, das wollen wir ja nochmal durch.
Verkauft eure NVIDIA Aktien nicht?
Nein, wir geben gar keine Hinweise auf Kaufen oder Verkaufen. Ich habe jedenfalls keine. Hast du NVIDIA Aktien?
Nein, ich habe gar keine Aktien.
Wenn wir aber jetzt darüber nachdenken, dass Google oder Alphabet plötzlich nicht nur für sich selbst TPUs entwickelt, sondern auch diese verkauft und wir wissen auch noch, dass Amazon bislang auch nur für sich selbst was entwickelt und es auch noch nicht verkauft und bislang sagen die auch, ne, haben wir nicht vor. Weiß man ja nicht, wie das in einem halben Jahr und einem Jahr aussieht. Dann können wir erst einmal feststellen, dass wir widerstreitende Kräfte dort hatten. Denn was ja häufig in den KI-Diskussionen zu kurz kommt, ist, dass Silicon Valley ja nicht das Silicon Valley als Einheit ist, sondern wir haben da sehr mächtige Akteure und die Frage ist ja auch, auf welche Seite werden die sich wann wie schlagen. Das heißt, das ist nicht einfach so ausgemacht, dass Silicon Valley herrscht und hat sich jetzt ganz und gar vielleicht mit Trump verbunden für ewig, sondern es kann durchaus sein, dass es da auch gewisse Aufspaltung geben wird. Und sollte beispielsweise jetzt Chechipiti, das jetzt gerade übertroffen wurde von Gemini, wie zumindest die Experten sagen und du bist ja wohl auch ganz begeistert, sollte sich das weiter so entwickeln, dass also Chechipiti, also die Company von Sam Altman, immer mehr in den Rückstand kommt, dann müsste man ja eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass Google nochmal ganz andere neue Adianzen schließen kann, von denen wir jetzt noch gar nicht wissen. Also wir haben da ja eigentlich so Machtblöcke, die sich gerade neu verschieben, je nachdem wo welche Innovationen sind und vor allem auch wo dann die entsprechende Hardware ist.
Also Google selbst ist ja schon so ein Machtkomplex.
Ja.
Das größte Medienunternehmen der Welt, größte Suchmaschine der Welt.
Sie arbeiten jetzt mit Anthropic zusammen.
Ja, das ist der größte Navigator für Autos und so rum durch die Welt. Überall der größte. Und dass man jetzt auch Anthropic damit reinholt, ist dafür, dass wir jetzt immer so von KI und hier, und das ist alles primär und zentral, in der großen Google-Firmengeschichte wird es vielleicht einfach nur so ein fogisches Ei. Also in dem einen Geschäftsfeld gab es mal für drei Jahre Konkurrenz. Dann hat man die einfach inkorporiert.
Oder es könnte ja auch anders sein. Also wir haben ja jetzt dann durch diese Deep-Sea-Geschichte erlebt, wie schnell also auch die Chinesen da vorankommen. Und die haben das ja damals als Open Source ausgegeben. Das heißt, die haben dann nicht ein Abo-Modell draus gemacht, sondern einfach gesagt, so, hier kann das jeder nutzen und weiter drinnen. Ja, aber das bedeutet ja erst einmal, wir haben es nicht zwingendermaßen mit der Entwicklung zu tun, die wir beim Silicon Valley, das sehr auf die Konsumenten ausgerichtet war, gesehen haben. Man geht zu Facebook und man bleibt sein Leben lang bei Facebook. Dann kommt man noch Instagram dazu. Und vielleicht noch für ganz wenige, ja, prozentual gesehen, Twitter. Und das war es dann. Und dann ist man dort ewig in diesem Netzwerk gefangen, hat sich diesem Monopol so ganz hingegeben. Das muss ja hier bei der KI nicht so sein. Das heißt also, die Frage ist ja auch, muss da eigentlich so ein Megakonzern daraus entstehen, der dann so eine erhebliche Macht hat, weil sie das entsprechende LLM anzubieten haben? Oder werden wir eben ganz viele LLMs haben überall? Was ich glaube, und wir eher an einen Punkt kommen, wo es dann nur noch ist, wer hat die entsprechende Hardware und kann die verkaufen? Und deswegen glaube ich, selbst jetzt auch Google so sehr auf die Hardware, weil sie wissen, auch wenn sie jetzt diesen enormen Strom nach vorne gemacht haben in der Entwicklung, das kann ja sein, dass wir drei Wochen schon hören, in China ist irgendwas Neues entwickelt worden, das schon viel besser ist als Gemina.
Also unser Olivia, meiner Webseite oder was auch immer, ist es total egal, wer diese kleinen KI-Aufgaben löst.
Da musst du nicht fragen, bist du bei Instagram?
Genau, das ist ein kleiner Klick. Also es gibt gar keinen Log-in-Effekt außer, und das hat ja, wir haben es mehrmals thematisiert, GBT festgestellt, OMI, als sie von vier auf fünf gegangen sind und die Leute diese emotionale Bindung plötzlich verloren haben. Ob das aber möglich ist, eine KI wie ein Freund ins Leben zu korporieren und dann später es nicht zu dulden, wenn der plötzlich ausgetauscht wird, das besprechen wir gleich.
Ich würde auch hier mal einhaken, kennt irgendjemand jemand oder ist jemand im Raum, der ein emotionales Verhältnis zu Chatchipity 4 entwickelt hatte, denn ich habe noch nie jemanden getroffen. Hier ist einer mit einem Jahr tatsächlich.
Direkt im Allerhalts.
Ja, ich arbeite in einer Schule und da tabe ich es auch mit Achtklässlerinnen zu tun, die dann auf Chatchipity einfach auch andauernd irgendwelche Fragen stellen. Zum Beispiel, was soll ich anziehen? Wie soll ich mich schminken?
Okay, das kann ich gut nachvollziehen. Also, es wurde gerade gesagt, dass in einer Schule Achtklässler fragen, was sollen sie anziehen und auch vielleicht Lebensprobleme oder so haben. Das ist ja das eine. Aber es wurde ja damals gesagt, mit Chatchipity 5 hätten sich sehr viele Menschen Chatchipity 4 zurück gewünscht, weil die Ansprache emotionaler gewesen sei und man in einer, ja, Art freundschaftlichen Beziehung dazu statt. Und ich wage zu bezweifeln, dass das wirklich auch eine größere Gruppe zutrifft. Das scheint mir ein bisschen so zu sein, ja, es sollen Menschen geben, die sich in Objekte verlieben, aber es sind dann doch äußerst wenige. Und ich vermute, sie sind alle schon mal in der Funk-Doku vorgekommen.
Ja, also die New York Times hat auch in The Daily dazu gemacht, wie enttäuscht die Leute immer wieder sind, wenn es Tokenfenster aufgebraucht sind und sie feststellen, GPT beginnt jetzt das Gespräch von vorne. Der Freund hat komplette Amnesie. Und das hat für Turbulenzen im Nachverkehr so.
Ich bin skeptisch. Also es gibt wahrscheinlich Leute, weil ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass das so eine ganz, ganz große Gruppe ist, wie das immer so gesagt wird. Ich habe doch den Eindruck, dass Leute vielleicht parasoziale Beziehungen mit unterführen, aber doch diese Art der Beziehungen auch vielleicht gar nicht brauchen oder vielleicht dann eher so auf einer rein sexuellen Ebene. Aber da ist das, vielleicht sind wir das sowieso noch mal auf einer ganz anderen Ebene. Aber bleiben wir mal bei der Ökonomie. Jetzt haben wir eben gehört, das könnten Wachstumsraten sein, wenn diese Rechnung so aufgeht von 6, 7 Prozent. Das ist ja wirklich BIP-Wachstum, wie man das hier lange nicht gesehen hat. Das sind dann chinesische oder indische Verhältnisse. Damit, sagt Tooze, erkläre sich auch, warum die Tech-Konzerne sich gerade gegenüber der Politik so verhalten, wie sie das tun.
Zum Verständnis des Trump-Phänomens ist das auch sehr wichtig. Denn wenn die Leute fragen, warum wehrt sich zum Beispiel das Kapital den Amerikanern nicht, geben diese vollkommen irrationelle Politik, dann ist die Antwort, dass die lautstärksten Teile des amerikanischen Kapitals eine solche Zukunftsperspektive haben. Das heißt, in den nächsten 18 Monaten bis zwei Jahren könnte sich alles entscheiden. Und wenn das der Fall ist, dann musst du mit der amerikanischen Regierung gut stehen. Mindestens für diese Zeit. Was danach kommt, interessiert niemanden, denn alles entscheidet sich in den nächsten zwei Jahren.
Man muss jetzt eigentlich die Füße stillhalten, weil man ja davon ausgeht, dass man sich so sehr in die Zukunft katakultiert, warum sich jetzt irgendwie eine blutige Nase holen für irgendetwas. Also alles erst mal so mitmachen. Und es ist wohl offenbar gar nicht so sehr das Staatsgeld, das dann kommt, aber dass man einfach seinen Weg zu gehen kann, ohne große Regulierungen.
Das glaube ich auch. Die nächsten 18 Monate wird dieser Markt sortiert.
Was passiert aber dann in den nächsten 18 Monaten? Also wie könnten die Resultate sein? Erstmal könnte es so sein.
Was passiert, wenn es tatsächlich zu einem absolut radikalen Arbeitsmarktshop kommt? Ich meine, Amerika ist obsessiv mit dem Chinaschock beschäftigt. Das war die relativ moderate Einschlag der chinesischen Importe vor 20 Jahren aufgrund des WTO-Beitritts von China. Da geht es um eine Viertelmillion Jobs im Jahr ungefähr, die im Verarbeitensektor verloren gegangen sind. Ich meine, bei KI könnten wir über eine Viertelmillion im Monat reden, wenn sich die Vorhersagen bewahrheiten.
Bedeutet, es würde ziemlich katastrophal werden. Also da ist der Chinaschock nichts. Was ist aber, wenn es jetzt nicht so kommt, dann könnte man sagen, wird es auch katastrophal.
Und dann haben wir es nach dem Berechnung von Gita Gruppinath, die jetzt gerade abgesägt worden ist beim IWF, also die frühere CheX-Volkswirtin, die dann die Nummer zwei war, die amerikanische Seite, die dann politisch nicht mehr tragbar war. Sie gab dem Economist als gewisserweise als Exit-Interview, eine Vorhersage, wo sie auf einmal dann nicht mehr ein Mundverbot hatte, sondern offen aussprach, dass die Befürchtung, dass in dem Fall eines Platzen der KI-Blase aufgrund der Heblum der amerikanischen Familien und Haushalte, den oberen zehn Prozent, die im Markt sehr aktiv sind, 20 Billionen an Werten verloren gehen könnten. Also wenn jetzt, wenn der Markt entsprechend der 90er-Jahre-Blase agistiert nach unten, dann, das wären 70 Prozent des amerikanischen BEPS an Vermögenswerten. Und das schlägt natürlich dann auf den Konsum. Das wäre die Formel für eine wirklich handfeste Restitution. Und das hat auch globale Ausweitung, weil das ist ja nicht nur eine amerikanische Story, sondern alle Portraits der gesamten Welt sind in Amerika investiert. Sie rechnet mit global 35 Billionen Dollar an Verlusten. Das schlägt über die gesamte vermögende Klasse der Welt ein.
Fast möchte man sie ihnen gönnen, aber wir sind natürlich dann alle mit in diesem Schwudel und werden nach unten gerissen, auch wenn wir nicht zur vermögenden Klasse gehören, die diese Aktienliste ist.
Kann man sich das verbildlichen? Das ist so, als würde in der Nordsee plötzlich noch mal Deutschland auftauchen. Fertig. Alle Häuser sind gebaut und jeder kann einfach der Welt wieder rüberziehen und dann Wertverlust der Häuser hier. Ja, so um diesem Maße.
Ja, es ist völlig absurd. Das heißt, aber eigentlich sind ja beide Zukunftsperspektiven nicht so aussichtsreich, wenn man diesen Hype nur sieht. Wir werden ja nachher mal ins Kleinteiligere gehen und dann vielleicht das nicht nur in so großen Szenarien versuchen zu fassen. Aber hier schwingt ja so viel mit, wenn wir über latente Räume reden. Was ist denn da eigentlich präsent und was ist absent? Also was ist denn eigentlich hier so interessant? Also wir haben es ja doch in China mit einem anderen Diskurs offenbar zu tun. Also der chinesische Diskurs ist ja auch einer, der gehypt ist von KI und glaubt da an große Möglichkeiten. Und der Staat unterstützt ja dann entsprechend diese Bewegungen. Aber wir haben ja in dem Silicon Valley und damit im Westen allgemein so ein Doomsday-Szenario. Wir haben diese ganzen Antichrist-Diskussionen von Peter Thiel. Wir sind da eigentlich so immer im Hollywood-Film schon angekommen. Und das bedeutet doch eigentlich, dass diese Fantasien, die ja vor allem kulturell erzeugt sind, also über Filme, Science-Fiction und alles erzeugt worden, dass diese jetzt gerade alle Köpfe sehr beherrschen, und zwar auch die der Investoren und der Macher Sam Altman und Co. Das heißt ja eigentlich, dass da Illusionsräume geschaffen wurden, die man jetzt versucht, mit viel Geld und mit viel Forschung und Entwicklung zu füllen, um die Illusionswelten in die Realität zu überführen. Und ich habe ein bisschen den Verdacht, dass das eine Illusionswelt bleibt und dass hier viele gerade ihren Fantasien nachjagen, ihren vielleicht auch Kindheitsvisionen, aber dass das nicht auf dieser Grundlage ist, dass wir eine solche Entwicklung erleben werden. Also du bist ganz glücklich mit Gemini und zeigst mir, wie toll jetzt Olivia unsere Kommentare lesen kann. Aber das sind ja alles Bereiche, wo man jetzt sagen kann, da bist du als Konsument noch der, da bist du auch bereit 20, vielleicht 50, vielleicht sogar 100 Euro im Monat für zu zahlen, dass du das machen kannst. Aber da sind wir ja weit entfernt von diesen Visionen, die dort eintreten müssten, um den Hype, der gerade an der Börse stattfindet, zu rechtfertigen.
Also das ist interessant, dass du so siehst, weil ich sehe gar keine Vision. Also niemand hat ja ein echtes Szenario. Alle sagen einfach nur ja, die allgemeine, generelle, irgendwas. Wenn die Chinesen ja sehr pragmatisch rangehen, die sagen einfach, ach ihr braucht Strom, kein Problem. Also man kriegt einfach Strom und dann Herr Landwirt, sie haben sieben Mähdrescher zu steuern. Also deichseln wir die jetzt alle elektronisch an ihr Büro und machen das dann irgendwie mit KI, die fahren so ein bisschen selbst. Da wird es halt einfach eingebaut. Da steht aber keiner daneben und erzählt erst eine große Story, sondern die kommen einfach und bauen das ein. Und in Amerika erzählt man sich einfach eine große Story, aber die ist so diffus. Also ich wüsste zum Beispiel gar nicht, welches Szenario hat denn jetzt, wenn wir die Texte gelesen von Amodal, von Anthropic und so, wie einfach die Zukunft gemalt wird. Nur da steht ja eigentlich nichts drin, außer immer so Ray-Curz-2 mäßig. Nee, das wird 40-fach schneller, die Entwicklung der Krebsforschung. Und ich denke mir so, ja ich weiß gar nicht, was einfach ist. Also ich habe die Krebsforschung einfach gar nicht verfolgt. Für mich nützt 40-fach gar nichts. Das ist aber die einzige Information, die in dem Text drin steht. Also stehe ich so ein bisschen blind daneben und denke mir, keine Ahnung, irgendwer scheint es ja zu glauben. Also die Bilanzen der Börsenwerte stimmen ja mit diesem Visionsteam. Aber die Umsätze nicht.
Genau, es muss ja realwirtschaftlich eingelöst werden. Ich würde auch nicht sagen, dass es wie bei der Dotcom-Blase ist. Also da gibt es ja diese berühmten Beispiele so, man hat eine Homepage gemacht, dort kommen als Adresse und dann hat man Geld bekommen.
Das war einfach eine digitale Druckmaschine, um das Prospekt einfach schnell zu machen. Und das war's.
Das war's. Das ist ja hier nicht der Fall. Also hier wird ja tatsächlich was gebaut. TPUs, GPUs, die Rechenzentren.
Aber mit denen wird ja noch relativ wenig gemacht.
Mit denen wird dann wenig gemacht. Beziehungsweise ja, wir können dann Abos abschließen. Und dann gibt es dann die speziellen Bereiche. Also dann müsste man eigentlich, wenn man über die KI-Revolutionen der Wirtschaft redet, ja nur noch mit hidden Champions reden, in Deutschland zum Beispiel, und fragen, was erleben die da jetzt gerade? Und ist das für die so relevant, was durch Gemini kommt? Oder ist es eher für die relevant, wie SAP jetzt gerade KI umgestaltet, weil die natürlich auch ziemlich geschlossene Netzwerke am liebsten anbieten wollen, in denen dann die Firmen für immer und ewig bleiben und immer noch irgendein weiteres Tool dazubuchen, um irgendwelche Prozesse zu optimieren? Deswegen frage ich mich da, ob vielleicht diese Konzentration auf diese großen Tech-Konzerne ein bisschen den Blick verunklaren.
Ja, total. Also diese großen Konzerne bauen ja keine Autos, die wir wiedererkennen wie, das ist ein Mercedes, das ist ein BMW, wie auch immer. Das steigt jemand ein und dann fährt er stolz damit rum, sondern genau gerade nicht. Alles, was nicht sichtbar ist, bauen diese großen Firmen und das alles Sichtbare bauen sie gerade nicht. Und von daher glaube ich auch, diese Börsenwerte sind so nicht gerechtfertigt. Sie können auch gar nicht gerechtfertigt werden. Und nachdem ich jetzt Olivia und so zusammengebaut habe, das ist so im Unsichtbaren und man kriegt das auch nicht sichtbar. So ich müsste wirklich wie ein Werbetext hinschreiben. Okay, das ist unsere Olivia, das ist unsere Neue Zwanzigerseite, das ist das, das ist hier. Dann müsste man wirklich ganz explizit unten hinschreiben, created with irgendwas, so Claude oder so. Und dann noch ein rotes Herbst dahinter, damit man so ein politisches Zeichen setzt. Aber der Rest ist...
Aber das wäre so ein bisschen wie, wenn du ein Bild aufhängst und dann dran schreibst, Dübel von Firma Wirt.
Genau.
Würde man auch nicht machen.
Der Rest ist unsichtbar. So wie ja heute viele menschliche Intelligenz auch unsichtbar ist. Also ich steige in einen Zug und ob heute Peter oder Ralf vorne drin sitzt und den fährt, also Entropic oder Claude, Entropic Produkte oder Open AI Produkte, macht ja gar keinen Unterschied. Und genauso lässt sich die Intelligenz natürlich grundsätzlich einfach durchschonglieren. Und diese Börsenwerte hängen aber in Sichtbarkeit. Das haben wir ja auch gesehen bei LMV Harder, wie sie heißen. Die haben, da waren ja auch einige überrascht, dass das jetzt plötzlich der heißste Mann der Welt und wie auch immer und so. Ja, wegen dieser Sichtbarkeit. Die haben kein Produkt, die haben nur Sichtbarkeit. So und genau das gilt für diese technischen Produkte genau gar nicht. Und von daher mal sehen, also wie Adam Tooze sagt, in den nächsten anderthalb Jahren wird sich das entscheiden und dann mal Bilanzen ziehen.
Weil das müssten dann schon extreme Fortschritte sein. Da geht es ja nicht darum, dass man nur sagt, das kann noch schneller Bilder generieren. Wir hören uns jetzt noch ein paar Clips an von Elena Esposito, die ja wie du auch in Belefeld studiert hat bzw. sie promoviert bei Niklas Luhmann. Sie ist also Luhmannianerin. Wir hören sie jetzt in einem Interview, das bei YouTube erschienen ist, bei der Herder-Buchhandlung Wien. Es hat 157 Aufrufe. Wir verdoppeln also jetzt fast. Ja, Latenz. Es ist da, aber es ist auch zugleich abwesend. Wir hören sie jetzt hier. Sie hat ja ein Buch geschrieben, das sich mal im Salon empfohlen hat, habe zu dieser maschinellen Intelligenz. Was sagt sie?
Es ist seit einigen Jahren klar, dass in der Arbeit, in der sie programmieren, die Nachahme der menschlichen Intelligenz keine wichtige Rolle spielt. Diese Maschinen arbeiten seit einigen Jahren so erstaunlich gut, aber die Programmier selbst sagen, die Vorschläge sind damit verbunden, dass sie nicht mehr versuchen, die Prozesse, die Arbeitsweise, das Verstehen, die unsere Intelligenz leitet, mit der Maschine nachzuahmen, sondern tun sie etwas ganz anderes. Die Maschinen versuchen nicht, die Inhalte zu verstehen. Sie suchen, wie man überall liest, nach Pattern, nach Regelmäßigkeit, nach Strukturen in den riesigen Datasets, die sie in Verfügung haben, um Ergebnisse zu produzieren, die für uns sinnvoll sind, aber nicht für die Maschine selbst.
Wir sollten also nicht, wenn wir über die maschinelle Intelligenz sprechen, darüber nachdenken, ob das so ist, wie unser Denken. Sondern diese ist eine andere Intelligenz oder eigentlich noch nicht mal eine Intelligenz im Sinne von Bewusstsein. Sondern man hat herausgefunden, die Maschinen sind besonders dann effektiv und schnell und werden besser, wenn sie nicht mehr länger danach ausgerichtet sind, Menschen nachzuahmen.
Ja, jetzt kann ich sie aber ein bisschen cosplayen als Soziologin. Denn was anderes als Regelmäßigkeiten, Strukturen, Muster sind denn Organisationen. Da geht es ja genau darum, das Chaos zu bändigen und Regelmäßigkeiten, Muster und Strukturen herzustellen. Von daher, da wir Arbeit ausschließlich in Organisationen bewältigen, selbst wir sind total auf Organisationen angewiesen, ist doch hier totale Passgenauigkeit.
Ja, es ist ja kein Widerspruch, oder?
Ne, also man kann eine Organisation nehmen und dann feststellen, okay, in den 18 Monaten hat Adam Tooze gesagt, sollte ich das entscheiden? Und dann hat sich doch nicht so viel entschieden. Kann durchaus passieren. Aber im generationellen Strukturwandel. Also wenn ich mir jetzt überlege, wer zusammen mit meinen Töchtern die Schule verlässt, die alte Arbeitswelt also gar nicht kennenlernt, aber den Ganzen, wir haben Hausaufgaben machen müssen. Also waren wir die Pioniere in der Anwendung von KI. Wenn die auf dem Arbeitsmarkt ankommen, sozusagen oder sogar neue Organisationen gründen, dann werden wir das, was wir gerade als Organisation bezeichnet, nicht wiedererkennen.
Also würdest du sagen, übernehmen dann die Menschen die Patterns der Maschine?
Nee, es wird zwischen Mensch und Maschine natürlich einfach neue Muster geben. Und wir kommen gleich auf Christian Uhle zu sprechen, ein junger Philosophen, der genau das forciert, zu sagen, wir haben 300.000 Jahre Menschheitsgeschichte, wir haben 400 Jahre Kapitalismus. Dass Menschen morgens zur Arbeit fahren und dort acht Stunden vor einem Computer sitzen, statt in ein menschliches Gesicht zu gucken, ist 30 Jahre alt. Das ist ein Phänomen, das behandeln wir heute als, war doch schon immer so. Es ist wie, wenn die AfD über Familie spricht, war doch schon immer so. So, wir sagen jetzt einfach, Mist, die Arbeit geht verloren. So, was verloren geht, ist dieses, der Mensch hat eine Struktur, ein Muster, ein Verhaltens, was auch immer, mit einer Maschine. Das wird die Maschine einfach mit sich selbst. Das macht keinen Sinn, dass eine Maschine nur dann mit einer anderen Maschine kommunizieren kann, wenn vorher ein Mensch auf Tasten drückt. So, das wird sich einfach ergeben.
Genau.
Und damit ergeben sich neue Räume für neue Arbeit und wir werden Organisationen in 30 Jahren, Arbeitsorganisationen, nicht wiedererkennen.
Das wird Esposito ja auch nicht leugnen, dass das so ist. Ich glaube, hier geht es ja noch mal…
Ich glaube, sie würde das genauso sagen, wie ich sie jetzt gesagt habe.
Ja, ich glaube, es geht ja noch mal sehr stark darum, zu sagen, es ist nicht eine menschliche Intelligenz. Das ist ja ihr Punkt, den sie hier machen will.
Das muss sie auch nicht sagen. Wer zur Arbeit geht, weiß, ich bin hier gerade nicht im Museum. Also Kreativität wird hier gerade verboten. Ich gehe zur Arbeit und werde da bezahlt, damit Kreativität verboten wird. Und das lässt sich natürlich alles sehr leicht ersetzen, was da stattfindet.
Nein, aber der Unterschied ist ja im Ziel von dem Beispiel, den du da aufmachst, und da, wenn wir jetzt über Schule diskutieren. Ein Lehrer steht vor der Klasse. Mit menschlicher Intelligenz hat man es auf beiden Seiten zu tun. Und dann versucht man also, sich an der menschlichen Intelligenz auszurichten und hat herausgefunden, dass man auf diese Weise, Pädagogen haben das gesagt, Sprache beibringen kann, Rechtschreibung beibringen kann, dass man Mathematikaufgaben in dieser Weise löst. Die KI geht ja vollkommen anders ran. Also bei der KI sagt man ja, die KI stellt sich nicht die Frage, was soll Goethe uns damit sagen oder so etwas. Und damit ist ja nur gemeint, dass es also einen fundamentalen Unterschied gibt, womit sich ja auch, wir werden da gleich noch zwei Clips hören, diese Illusion verpuffen sollte, dass also die übermächtige KI kommt, die dich beherrscht.
Nee, es geht ja konkret darum, wenn wir einen Lehrer in Reihe eins. Lehrer haben ja verschiedene Aufgaben. Zum Beispiel die Ansprache an die Schülerschaft, die Informationsvermittelnde. Hier kommt die Ansage, ich male ein Teil vom Bild, bitte mal das ab, wie auch immer. Das ist die Information. Das ist prüfungsrelevant. Und dann gibt es auf dem Rückweg die Nachfrage des Schülers. So, du hast ja immer noch dieses Bild, der Lehrer steht vorne und macht eine Ansage.
Ja, so wünsche ich es mir. So hatte ich es immer gehabt.
Genau, was wir uns vorstellen können aber, und wir haben heute schon das Segeln, das selbstgesteuerte Lernen, dass die Ansprache des Lehrers schon relativ weit wegfällt. Also man hat eine Stunde Physik und dann hat man eine Stunde Segeln. Und in der Segelstunde hat man Physikaufgaben, die man dann selbstgesteuert lernt. Da steht also nicht der Lehrer vorne. Na ja, Segeln, selbstgesteuertes Lernen. Das ist also die Abkürzung Segeln.
Ja, und siehst du doch, wo ist das dazu?
Hier funktionieren die Schulen auch so. Und jetzt ist ja das Interessante, dass wir es durch KI schaffen könnten, die Rückfragen aus der Schülerschaft ein bisschen häufiger zu bedienen, als es bisher beim Betreuungsverschlüssel 1 zu 20 und der Programmatik Ansprache des Lehrers möglich ist. So, und diese Räume sind schon längst da. Denn ich erlebe das ja zu Hause, wenn kein Lehrer anwesend ist, sondern nur ich und ich dann sage, frag doch GBT.
Ganz, ganz richtig. Ich möchte da überhaupt nicht widersprechen. Es ging ja nur darum zu sagen, dass Menschen nicht in dieser Art und Weise ein Mustern lernen, wie das die Maschinen tun. Sie tun das ja offenbar. Sonst würden sie auch nicht so fundamental Fehler machen, bei denen man denkt, das wäre ja einem Menschen niemals passiert. Ich gebe dir ein Beispiel. Ich habe letzte Woche Chachi Kiti gefragt als Test, um mich schon vorzubereiten hier auf den heutigen Abend. Bitte nenn mir zehn blonde Schauspielerinnen aus Hollywood der 90er Jahre. Dann kommen acht richtige Antworten. Und zwei Antworten sind aber fundamental falsch. Da kommt Neve Campbell und Central Bullock. Sie sind offensichtlich nicht blond. Das wäre einem Menschen und auch Kindern nie passiert, weil sie sagen, die ist ja nicht blond, die ist ja brünett. Und da gibt es ja einen ganz erheblichen Unterschied genauso auch bei solchen Dingen, dass die KI, wenn man ihr ein Wort nennt und fragt, wie viel Mal kommt da der Buchstabe P oder M vor, dass sie sich damit unterverzählt.
Ja, das ist schon antike Geschichte.
Nein, das ist noch vor wenigen Wochen vorgekommen. Das soll jetzt mit Gemini nicht mehr vorkommen. Aber wir sind da ja schon in Bereichen, womit ich nur sagen will, ob das jetzt eine Kinderkrankheit, die jetzt inzwischen ausgestanden ist mit den blonden Haaren, das ist ja jetzt von letzter Woche bei Chet-GPT gewesen, weiß nicht, wie Gemini diese Frage jetzt beantwortet. Und vielleicht hat aufgrund meines Widerspruchs jetzt auch Chet-GPT gelernt. Jedenfalls das, das passiert, zeigt ja, dass es ein fundamental anderes Herangehen ist, als das Menschen tun. Weil Menschen würden nicht diese falsche Aussage treffen, weil sie so offensichtlich ver-
Ja, okay. Aber bei der Fragestellung sage ich, zwei Jahre warten und dann nochmal gucken, ob sie das wirklich nicht hinkriegen.
Nein, mir geht es nicht darum, kann man das optimieren. Natürlich wird man das optimieren können. Ich glaube nicht, dass ich in einigen Jahren nochmal diese Anekdote erzählen könnte. Was ich nur damit sagen will, daran zeigt sich, dass es ein anderer Ansatz ist, als wir den bei Menschen finden. Wir haben doch schon das damals beim autonomen Fahren gesehen. Du willst ja nicht mal sagen, das ist ja gar nicht schlimm. Aber wir haben das ja beim autonomen Fahren, haben wir die Diskussion ja auch schon gehabt, dass die Erkennung und das Verständnis von Menschen ein Verständnis ist und die KI versteht nicht. Und das ist auch gar nicht schlimm für das, was sie da tun soll. Nur diese Differenz, glaube ich, sollten wir machen, damit wir nicht in diese Konfusion hinein geraten, die gerne das Silicon Valley gerade produziert.
Alles richtig. Ich differenziere jetzt wieder diese zwei. Es geht gar nicht um KI. Wenn wir selbst ohne KI die Arbeitswelt betrachten, stellen wir einfach fest, für 80 Prozent der Jobs, die da erledigt werden, reicht das Schöpfungslevel von Gedanken einer Maus. Und das ist einfach so. Wenn ein Kind zu Hause sitzt und Schulaufgaben aufhat und ich frage, welche sind das denn? Und deshalb geht es um Mathe, das Einmaleins bis zu dreistelligen Zahlen. Dann geht es darum, eine Frage nach der anderen zu stellen, bei der das Multiplikatorenergebnis bis 100 reicht. Dafür brauche ich keine KI, dafür brauche ich auch keine wirkliche Intelligenz. Ich brauche aber eine Maschine, die die Aufgabe versteht, die jetzt zu erledigen ist. Und GPT stellt ganz geduldig diese Fragen, beantwortet ganz geduldig diese Fragen, stellt die nächsten Aufgaben. So, dass ich dafür nicht die gottgleiche einen neuen Goethe, einen von 1000 Mozarts brauche, das können wir nicht immer wieder in diesem Podcast behandeln.
Nein, ich frage den Mozart nicht. Ich würde aber zum Beispiel sagen, dass gerade bei diesem Bürojobssinn, oder beschreibst du das nicht, der Fall ist, dass das leicht zu lösen aufgab. Ich glaube, dass David Graver da, bei allem Respekt, ein bisschen zu sehr auf die Bullshitjobs geachtet hat. Und ja, wir alle kennen sie. Und wer bei LinkedIn sich auffällt und sieht, welche Poster abgesetzt sind, dann denkt man, oh lieber Gott, und die machen auch noch Berufe. Aber ja, das mag es alles geben. Aber wenn wir uns dann gleich ansehen, wie komplex doch sehr viele Fragen, die dort im Büro vor einem Computer sitzend sind und wie viel menschliche Koordination das auch braucht, um dann möglicherweise diese Tabelle richtig auszufüllen, ist das auch eine Überschätzung des Phänomens Bullshitjobs. Ich, also das ist jetzt meine Prognose. Vielleicht werden wir uns in zwei Jahren dann hier erleben, wie ich mehr Kulpa sage und mich in den Staub werfe. Aber meine Prognose ist, dass diese große Disruption dann nicht kommen wird. Ja, da werden Bullshitjobs wegfallen. Aber wir werden sehr viele dieser Jobs weiterhin brauchen, weil sie nicht nur so eine Laune des Kapitalismus sind, dass man dummes Zeug hervorgebracht hat, sondern eigentlich schon alles sehr auf Effizienz getrimmt. Und wir werden das nicht alles wegrationalisieren können. Also ich bin da überhaupt nicht der Ansicht.
Ja, lass uns noch schnell deine Episode, denn es könnte sein, da ich mal nachher Markus Gabriels Clips spiele, dass man schon morgen feststellt, den brauchen wir wirklich nicht mehr. Den müssen wir das heute noch schaffen.
Da bin ich mir ganz sicher. Wir hören weiter.
Man spricht sehr oft von Opacity, also dass die Maschinen so grundsätzlich unverständlich sind. Aber nicht nur für sie oder für mich, die wir nicht Experte sind, nehme ich an. Für mich ist auch so eine Kaffeemaschine in Grunde Transparenz. Ich weiss nicht, wie die Maschine funktioniert. Aber die Neuigkeit von dieser Maschine ist, dass selbst die Hersteller können nicht nachvollziehen, wie die Maschine zu der Ergebnis gekommen ist.
Ist aber auch gar nicht schlimm.
Weil die Maschinen verarbeiten die Daten nicht nur schneller und massiver, als sie können, mit höherer Komputationsfähigkeit, aber sie tut es auf eine Weise, wo sie diese Patterns identifizieren, die für uns keinen Sinn machen. Das sind nicht Pattern, die wir verstehen könnten, auf so viele verschiedene Dimensionen zugleich, die im Grunde für die Menschen nicht nachvollziehbar sind. Das Interessante ist aber, wie wir auch sagen, dass gerade deshalb die Maschinen so effizient sein können. Das heisst, es gibt eine Art Trade-off, wie wir sagen, also Konkurrenz zwischen Interpretabilität, Verständigkeit der Maschine und ihrer Effizienz, dass viele von diesen Maschinen arbeiten auf diese überraschende, anscheinend kreative Weise, gerade weil sie nicht nötig haben, die Inhalte zu verstehen und deshalb nicht nötig haben, für uns verständlich zu sein.
Die müssen nichts verstehen, sind gerade dann besonders praktisch vielleicht für uns. Sie kommt auf die doppelte Kontingenz zu sprechen.
Die Köpfe, die Gedanken von den Teilnehmern an der Kommunikation zum Glück können total und untersichtig bleiben. Ich brauche ihre Gedanken nicht zu lesen, um ihnen jetzt zu kommunizieren. Und sie brauchen nicht meine Gedanken zu lesen, damit die Kommunikation erfolgreich funktioniert. Der Punkt ist nur, die Kommunikation verlangt, dass wir etwas produzieren, der unseren Kommunikationspartner ermöglicht, seine eigenen Gedanken, seine eigenen Informationen zu produzieren, die interessant, informativ sein können, ohne an der Überlachtung unserer Gedanken gebunden zu sein. Das heißt, jeder entwickelt seine eigenen Gedanken und die Kommunikation leistet eine erstaunliche Koordination zwischen dieser verschiedenen Informationsproposition.
Ja, auch das ist ein maßgebender Beitrag des Menschen zum Erfolg von Organisation. Du kennst diesen Spruch aus fast jedem Hollywood-Film. Irgendwas ist above my pay grade. Ich folge hier nur einer Dienstanweisung. Ich verstehe das große Ganze nicht. Wir können das der Maschine nicht vorwerfen im Sinne von, nee, dich wird man nie nützlich einsetzen können. Du hast ja gar kein Weltmodell, kein Verständnis von irgendwas und so. Muss sie nicht. Kein Mitarbeiter braucht das. Auch der große Chef kommt als post-heroischer Manager hereingeschwebt, löst so ein paar Probleme und zwar nicht, weil sie sattlich anspruchsvoll sind, sondern weil die unteren Ebenen so im Konflikt sind, dass halt einer mal mit einer etwas höheren Rangordnung einfach sagen kann, das machen wir jetzt so, wie der Kump sich anrufen lässt, blau statt rot wird heute gefärbt, heute Nacht arbeiten alle weiteren Färben, blau statt rot. Also ich sehe hier große Passgenauigkeit.
Sie kommt dann auf AGI zu sprechen. Ist das eine Option? Kann das wirklich Realität werden, was da im Silicon Valley erhofft wird?
Die Furcht, dass diese Maschine endgültig intelligent wird, eine general intelligence entwickeln können und dass sie sogar eine super intelligence haben können, dass sie intelligenter als wir werden und dann das Oberhand nehmen können, dass sie mächtiger werden können und selbst entscheiden können, was sie machen wollen, uns nicht mehr gehorchen usw. Und das ist natürlich eine besorgniserregende Perspektive, worüber ich mich keine richtige Sorge machen kann. Weil wenn man guckt, wie die Maschinen in der Tat funktionieren, sie haben keine eigenen Wünsche und es gibt keine richtige Konkurrenz und Competition zwischen Menschenintelligenz und Maschinenintelligenz. Es ist einfach nicht realistisch. Das mache ich mir keine Sorge. Competition zwischen dieser Alien-Mind, dieser Nicht-Mensch-Intelligenz und unserer Intelligenz scheint mir einfach nicht empirisch begründet zu sein.
Bedeutet aber dann, dass das, was Adam Tooze ausgeführt hat, eigentlich mit Esposito so gelesen werden kann, dass die Blase auf jeden Fall platzen wird. Denn das kann nicht eingelöst werden.
Sie sagt auch?
Dass die Mensch-Intelligenz für das Planete schädlich sein kann, kann wohl sein. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass die künstliche Intelligenz diejenigen ist, die das beurteilen, beobachten kann und jetzt was dagegen tun kann.
Ja, das wird so kommen. Und die Frage ist, woran liegt das genau? Es ist nicht einfach die Antwort, die menschliche ist zu unterscheiden von der künstlichen, die passt irgendwie. Also das ist irgendwie so anders, keine Ahnung. Also in die Richtung, die du es immer drängst. Das ist eine Intelligenz eigener Qualität. Genau, sie ja auch. Und das kann man ja, also was sie, ich will es jetzt hier nicht in den Mund legen, aber das Gedankengebäude, aus dem sie kommt, ist ja dieses systemtheoretische, sie hat ja dann diesen schönen Lebenswandler wie Niklas Luhmann, das in Bielefeld einfach gesagt wird, wenn man es da ja kein Budget mehr für ihre Forschungsarbeit, also sagt er, dann arbeite ich jetzt in der Toskana. So, und dann sitzt sie halt da und schreibt dort und sie kommt ja aus der Teilen. So, und dieses Gedankengebäude dahinter ist ja eine Kommunikationstheorie, die einfach sagt, Kommunikation ist nicht, wenn eine Information und so weiter, sondern wenn eine Information und das ist das Nurum, mitgeteilt wird. Es geht also nicht einfach um ein Sender sendet eine Information, sondern der Empfänger versteht, diese Information ist nicht random oder für mich einfach interessant, sondern sie wurde mir mitgeteilt. Sie ist eine Mitteilung, sie richtet sich an mich. Ich kann sie einfach ignorieren, aber schon das Ignorieren ist so ein kleiner kognitiver Aufwand, denn ich muss nicht nur die Information sachlich ignorieren, sondern auch, okay, ich wurde angesprochen und ich reagiere nicht darauf. Kommunikation ist also rückwärts, nicht vom Sender, der eine Information, sondern rückwärts. Der Empfänger stellt fest, es gibt eine Differenz zwischen Information und Mitteilung. Von der Mitteilung macht den Unterschied. Und jetzt ist die Frage, was steckt alles in der Information, die man sieht mit, ah, es wurde mir mitgeteilt. Was steckt da eigentlich alles drin? Denn wir haben ja immer wieder dieses Phänomen, dass irgendwie behauptet wird, ganz viel ist so indirekte, nonverbale Kommunikation, das ist ganz wichtig, der Körperbezug und so weiter und so fort. Und Peter Fuchs, auch aus dieser Ecke, Denkrichtung, hat einen sehr guten Text geschrieben dazu. Der heißt, wer hat wozu und weshalb überhaupt Gefühle? Und da kann man es ein bisschen nachlesen, denn er sagt, Gefühle, also da können wir uns beide darauf einigen, das Urmenschliche, das was wirklich uns von Maschinen, und zwar allen Maschinen, auch den, die wir heute haben, unterscheidet sind, wir haben Gefühle. Aber Gefühle sind nicht so eine mystische Binnenvitalität oder irgendeine biologische Energie, die wir haben und die dann irgendwie ausbricht, sondern Gefühle spielen dann eine Rolle, wenn man in Kommunikation mitteilen möchte, dass etwas nicht kommunizierbar ist. Und dann sagt man einfach, ich bin wütend oder stellt es halt dar, dass man wütend ist. Und dann müssen alle rätseln und fragen, was will er uns eigentlich mitteilen? Also wir sehen die Mitteilung. Er erhebt die Faust, er zerschlägt irgendwas oder die liebevolle Geste oder was weiß ich. Und dann muss der Empfänger aber überlegen, was genau ist jetzt die Information? Ich erahne, da ist so eine Mitteilung an mich und die geht in so eine spezielle Richtung. Denn, und das ist das Besondere, die Gefühle, anders als andere Kommunikationsinhalte, die prägend sein können, haben so eine Art Stoppschild, eine Reflektionssperre. Sie sagen eben ausdrücklich, Achtung, hier ist etwas zu beachten, aber genau das ist gerade nicht kommunizierbar. Ich kann gerade noch dieses große Schild hochhalten. Achtung, Achtung, hier geht es um Gefühle. Und dann lohnt es sich auch, also man kann dann therapeutisch einen Tiefgang machen. Aber typischerweise ist das dann, ja, darum bist du jetzt auf dich gestellt. Der andere kann zwar ganz viele Versuche unternehmen, irgendetwas mitzuteilen, aber vielleicht gelingt es nicht immer. Also, und da hört man schon, okay, das geht jetzt in diesem Bereich Latenz. Indirekter Anteil von Kommunikation, Nonverbalität. So, und jetzt sind wir aber in Gesprächen mit Maschinen. Also erstmals überhaupt kann die Menschheit kommunizieren mit Nichtmenschen. Allein dadurch, dass die Maschinen ganz klar machen, du hast mir eine Frage gestellt, ich teile dir jetzt eine Antwort mit. Das ist nicht einfach nur eine Suchergebnissache von Google oder so, die einfach kurz aufgelistet wird und jeder, der das reinträgt und die gleichen anderen Suchsignale mitbringt, kriegt halt so ungefähr das gleiche Ergebnis, sondern das ist wirklich maßgeschneidert auf meine Fragestellung, die ich hatte. Also hier unbestreitbar ist eine echte Mitteilung. Ich weiß nicht genau, was die Maschine mir sagen will, aber sie versucht mir jetzt entgegenzukommen, sie macht mir irgendwie ein Angebot und dann sagt Elia Sutz-Kever, naja, die Frage ist ein bisschen unscharf, die Antwort, weil deine Frage halt auch unscharf war. Offenbar hast du, und das ist ja der große Erfolg von diesen neuen Maschinen, dass ganz viele so gefühlige, therapeutische, Lebenshilfefragen stellen und die Maschine trotzdem antwortet. Und während es vorher immer noch hieß, ja, bloß nicht googeln bei irgendwelchen Krankheitsfällen, da kommt man in die Teufelsküche, heißt jetzt plötzlich, selbst von Alena Büchs, wow, das ist super nützlich, in die Richtung sollten wir gehen, ja, versucht mal alle euch mit GPT zu therapieren. Und das ist ja was Neues. Und dem gehen wir jetzt nach mit unserem Lieblingsphilosophen, der heißt Markus Gabriel. Vorher hören wir aber andere menschliche Stimmen, denn einige verirren sich dann doch sehr. Hier zum Beispiel der Moderator des SWR, wie heißt die Philosophie, Sternstunde Philosophie.
Das Schweizer Fernsehen.
Das Schweizer Fernsehen, die Sternstunde Philosophie. Ein Moderator, der offenbar alles verliert, also alles Menschliche gibt er sofort, erlegen einfach, war jetzt irgendwas mit KI.
Und auch diese da, die sie sehen, auch die existiert nicht. Sie ist eine Influencerin erschaffen durch KI mit Hunderttausenden von Followern. Und kürzlich hat sogar ihre eine Mutter, ihre verstorbene kleine Tochter als Avatar wieder zum Leben erweckt. Was bedeuten diese rasanten Entwicklungen für unsere Gesellschaft, für die Arbeitswelt der nächsten Jahre und für unsere Beziehungen?
So, dieser Typ hat jetzt einfach gesagt...
Das ist Yves Bossard. Der ist übrigens sehr nett. Ich habe ja schon mit dem Sendung gemacht.
Er ist sehr nett, aber er ist auch so ein bisschen...
Na ja, also das ist ja der Einstieg so jetzt......können wir Tote zum Leben dann erwecken. Genau.
So, hat hier wirklich jemand jemanden zum Leben erweckt? Oder ist das ein sprachlicher Fehlgriff? Ist das ein Missverständnis? Richtig. Hat hier einfach eine Mutter, das hören wir ja auch gleich noch mal im Detail, offenbar einfach eine Mitteilung. Sie ist ja verantwortlich für was ist eine Kommunikation. Er hat sie einfach eine Mitteilung verstanden, wo gar keine ist oder etwas fehlinterpretiert. Hat da jemand eine Maschine so ertüchtigt, dass diese Frau in die Irre geführt wurde? Denn eins können wir sagen, wir sehen das gleich im Detail so, das Kind lebt nicht wieder, das ist tot. So, wir wollen aber, und an ihm bleiben wir dran, er kriegt gleich von Christian Uhle so ein bisschen den Hintern versäulen, so wie du das auch gerne machst. Und wir kontrastieren das alles mit Markus Gabriel, der bei unserem richtigen Podcastser, Mats Sram.
Ja, dann mache ich das beim Moderatoren, dass ich denen so eins mitgebe, wenn ich mit ihm rede oder?
Nein, aber Menschen, die das Menschliche durch KI-Bedrohung aus dem Blick verlieren, da haust du ja gerne.
Also du hast jetzt eben so einen Widerspruch zwischen uns produziert, um den jetzt wieder glatt zu ziehen.
Genau, genau, genau. Also ja, ich versuche jetzt wieder Konzepts.
Ein bisschen eigenartiger, maximalistisch, wenn ich das sage. Ich fahre mit Stefan, das ist ein Monat hier, ja, durch Frankfurt. Also wir waren aufgenommen, waren ein bisschen schräg dran. Dann kamen wir mit dem Auto dahin, da ist er bei mir mitgefahren. Es ging sehr safe voran und da Fußgänger, da Fahrradfahrer, da fahren Autos, da ist noch eine Baustelle und so. Man laviert sich da irgendwie so durch. Und Stefan sitzt ganz entspannt neben mir und redet in einer Tour. Ja, macht jetzt bald alles KI, ist bald alles automatisch. Heute alles autonomes fahren. Und ich wurschtle mich da durch diese schrecklichen Straßen in Frankfurt, die man niemals einer KI überlassen können. Man müsste sie auf eine Milliarde eventualitäten vorbereiten. Und Stefan ganz entspannt, ne, ne, das macht alles gut. Also auch in fünf Jahren werde ich dich noch durch Frankfurt fahren müssen, mein Lieber.
Na mal sehen, also in 20 Jahren brauche ich das ja wirklich. Bis dahin ist das hoffentlich erledigt. Und ich möchte heute schon die Proande machen.
In 20 Jahren, dann reden wir schon wieder von einem ganz anderen Haubeigestand.
Es wäre schon nächstes Jahr möglich. Es ist nur noch ein Störfaktor im Straßenverkehr, das ist ein Menschenabsteuer.
Ja klar, wenn ich alles vereinige von dem, was die Wirklichkeit ausmacht, dass ich dann das machen kann, ist klar. Ich kann auch hier eine Modelleisenbahn aufbauen und sagen, ja, wunderbar, hier klappt es doch mit der deutschen Bahn.
Naja, das, das mit der Modelleisenbahn, also Zhen Zhen hat das jetzt gemacht. In China wurde diese 30 Millionen-Stadt auf den Zentimeter genau kartografiert. Da ist sie also, eine Modelleisenbahn. Und klar, wir haben da ein anderes Repressionsregime, das sagt, sorry, aber sie haben ihre Tasche auf der Straße abgestellt, drei Jahre Gefängnis. Aber da kann man die Straße so bereinigen, dass man einfach mit dem Auto da durchfahren kann. Also, Markus Gabriel sitzt bei Matze, unserem Lieblingspodcaster, und beide staunen ganz ehrfürchtig.
Die sagen im Grunde genommen längst vorher, welche Emotionen ich als nächstes haben werde wahrscheinlich. Also, wer in der Stimmung ist, so schnell scrollt, so tippt mit der Stimme, spricht in der Audiofunktion. Jemand, der sich so ausdrückt, fühlt sich wahrscheinlich gleich so.
Das ist jetzt schon der Fall?
Längst. Wow.
Wir sind ja hier schon fast wieder beim Schirrach-Gespräch. Schirrach erzählt nochmal, ja, dann weiß schon die Plattform, ob jemand schwanger ist oder ob jemand schwul oder hetero ist. Und dann denkt man so, ja klar, warum denn auch nicht? Wenn da Bilder angeguckt werden, wenn sie Schwangerschaftstests bestellt werden, dann weiß man vielleicht manches. Und hier auch, ja, wenn man in eine solche Maschine die Muster auswerten kann, mit zittriger Stimme lauthals irgendwas reinbrüllt, dann wird sie irgendwie denken, vielleicht ein bisschen sauer gerade.
Genau. Also dafür braucht man tatsächlich noch keine KI. Also das war wirklich zu Schirmeres digitaler Debatte seit 2010 bis 2014 dann genau so Thema. Eigentlich sind wir 15 Jahre weiter. Und die beiden haben sich auch, das hört man ja hier so am Tonfall, komplett der KI ergeben. Also da ist gar nicht mehr die Frage, ob man hier noch und so weiter. Und wir hören es jetzt auch, während Adam Tooze vorhin die Black Box schön als schwarze Kiste übersetzt hat, um zu zeigen, im Markt ist vielleicht ein bisschen viel Obskurität, die dazu führt, dass man 5 Billionen Börsen wert. Und wir sagen, wow, das ist eine Mega-Blase. Dasselbe gibt es auch in der intellektuellen Dimension. Markus Gabriel bringt jetzt hier so viel schwarze Romantik und dunkle Magie rein, dass man sich fragt, sorry, aber das ist eine intellektuelle Blasenbildung. Das wird auch poppen. Wir wissen nicht genau, wie das dann aussieht, aber.
Und zwar ging das los. Interessant, soweit meine Recherche. Bing, die nicht von Microsoft. Darüber gibt es auch diesen berühmten Bericht eines New York Times. Ich glaube, ich war es Journalisten, der mit Bings KI gespielt hat, bis dann Bing sagte, nicht sich selber Sidney nannte und sagte, ich bin übrigens in dich verliebt und deine Frau liebt dich nicht wirklich und so weiter. Und der Journalist war sehr davon überrascht, dass das System.
Ja, der Journalist, ja, vielleicht einer der meist gelesenen Texte international von Kevin Roos damals zum Thema und so. Irgendein Journalist, keine Ahnung.
Ebenso reagiert. Und das war ja so einer dieser Durchbruchstories und die jüngsten Geschichten, die man hört von Selbstmorden und so weiter, wenn Menschen zu lange mit dem System interagiert haben. Dadurch ist das so ein bisschen mehr die Aufmerksamkeit getreten.
Die Leute springen alle aus den Fenstern raus, weil sie mit der Prei lange kommunizieren. Also ja, es gibt immer irgendwelche solche Fälle. Und das ist aber, also man muss einfach sich mal vergegenwärtigen, dass der Anteil junger Menschen in den USA, glaube ich, bei 75 Prozent bei regelmäßiger KI-Nutzung liegt. Und dann kommt alles mal irgendwie vor.
Ja, genau. Also du hast ja vorhin die Politik angesprochen, die machen alles kostenlos, Open AI auch. Also 800 Millionen Nutzer und 5 Prozent bezahlen. Also da wissen wir genau, die ganzen Teenager und so weiter, jeder benutzt das da. Und es kommt natürlich dann zu Verwerfungen, die auch statistisch nicht so vielleicht die allergrößte Rolle spielen, aber journalistisch natürlich entsprechend thematisiert werden. Jetzt zu diesem jüdkoreanischen Beispiel. Klar, Markus Gabriel redet so darüber und ist auch irgendwie so erregt, weil das jetzt irgendwie alles ganz so war und so. Und wie heißt nochmal der Schweizer Moderator?
Yves Bossard.
Yves Bossard. Ich weiß nicht genau, also ich finde, wir hören das gleich. Er hat den richtigen Gesprächspartner mit Christian Uhle, der ihn versucht, wieder einzunorden.
Ja, und das und das andockt bei unseren tiefsten Emotionen und Sehnsüchten. Also nicht nur der Angst, alleine zu sein so, sondern auch Umgang mit Trauer zum Beispiel. Also Trost bei einem Fall, ich habe es in der Anmoderation gesagt, wo jemand die Tochter verloren hat. Und ich möchte mit Ihnen das kurz anschauen, weil es so bewegend ist, da trifft eine Mutter im Rahmen dieser koreanischen Reality-TV-Serie Meeting You heißt die, da trifft sie ihre Tochter im virtuellen Raum, wo die Tochter verstorben ist.
Das südkoreanische Fernsehformat Meeting You führte ein entsprechendes KI-Experiment mit einem Avatar durch.
Eine Mutter wollte so erneut von ihrem verstorbenen Kind Abschied nehmen. Millionen Menschen schauen zu.
Ich möchte sie einfach noch einmal sehen können. Koste es, was es wolle.
Mama, wo warst du?
Mama, immer noch!
Ich auch, Mama.
Unmittelbar nach der Ausstrahlung folgt der Shitstorm.
Es ist widerlich, einer Mutter so etwas anzutun.
Schämt euch.
Es sieht wie ihre Tochter aus, ist sie aber nicht.
Es ist nur ein Hologramm.
Also hier kommt ja so ein Paradox. Sie sieht ihre Tochter, die Tochter bedeutet die ganze Welt, die ganze Welt sieht aber sie und nicht die Tochter, sondern wie sie in so einem Green Screen steht. So, und das ist natürlich eine Situation, die mehr medial zu betrachten ist, weil hier sitzt einfach eine Redaktion wie bei Frauentausch oder Bauer sucht Frau und überlegt sich, was könnten wir jetzt mit KI so machen? Und dann kommt die auf so eine Idee. Also da wird einfach eine emotionale Schieflage extrem ausgebeutet für so eine Publikumsbespaßung. Und das ist natürlich pervers. Nur das kann man halt auch genauso beschreiben. Da muss man nicht als Fernsehmotorrader da sitzen, so sagen, das ist so bewegen, das zu sehen. Und ja, Uhle, schauen sie sich das an und liebe Zuschauer zu Hause, sie auch an.
Völlig richtig. Also das ist auch eigentlich nicht künstliche Intelligenz, sondern menschliche Blödheit.
Genau.
Oder auch.
Und da kritisiert ja die KI nicht, wie Esposito sagt, sondern da kann die Redaktion machen, was sie will.
Man muss die Redaktion dafür kritisieren. Und alles andere ist ja, natürlich werden, wenn Bilder auftauchen von Menschen, die einem wichtig waren, die nicht mehr in der Nähe sind, Emotionen geweckt und dann wird es hier nochmal besonders verstärkt. Aber das ist ja nun wirklich nicht das, worauf jetzt die Entwicklung der KI hinauslaufen wird.
Ja, wir könnten jetzt also sagen, diese Frau wurde in die Irre geführt. Sie wurde in eine Falle gelockt. Sie hat sich von einer Oberfläche blenden lassen, hinter der gar nichts ist. Und jetzt hören wir mal Markus Gabriel.
Individuell kann ja jeder seine Trauarbeit machen, wie er will. Früher war das zum Beispiel viel stärker der Fall, dass man auf den Friedhof ging, um dort mit den Toten zu sprechen, am Grabe stehend. Dazu besteht ja auch erst mal kein Grund, das dort zu tun. Also da gibt es ja auch keine Antwort, ja. Aber das ist eine Form, mit Trauer umzugehen. Aber dann hat man ja auch nicht gesagt, das hat ja irgendwas mit künstlicher Intelligenz oder so zu tun. Also das ist ein ähnliches Szenario. Da hat man halt einen Grabstein hingestellt und hier stellt man mal ein Hologramm hin. Das ist aber eigentlich kein qualitativer Unterschied.
Genau. Bericht da mal mit unserer Sehgewohnheit. Ja, also wir sehen hier schon ein Novum. Markus Gabriel auch ganz aus dem Häuschen.
Und was die Systeme machen jetzt, ist sie dringen in diesen Raum des Ausdrucks unserer Gefühle ein und eben nicht mehr bloß in die Sprache. So und das finde ich wahnsinnig, weil es mir viel klarer gemacht hat als jemals zuvor, wie wichtig Emotionen sind als die Grundlage dessen, was wir sprachlich eigentlich ausdrücken.
Ein Soziologiebuch war los, Seite eins, hätte hier geholfen. Das ist mir völlig unklar, wie man feststellt, dass die menschliche Kommunikation natürlich nicht. Also was er hier gerade gesagt hat ist ja, also lieber Matze, ich war gestern in einem magischen Ort, eine Oper und ich habe festgestellt, vielleicht ist das, also ich sag's einfach wie es ist, aber es macht voll den Unterschied, ob der Text gesungen wird oder gesprochen. Das ist die Botschaft da gewesen.
Ja, ja.
So, und das verstehe ich einfach nicht. Wie, also klar, ich will jetzt nicht die große Markus Gabriel Kritik ein und so.
Na ja, doch man wusste das mal, also das ist ja, ich frage mich jetzt auch so, für ihn, wie war das denn bislang mit Menschen zu kommunizieren? Nur so Informationsbeschaffung oder was? Spucken Informationen aus und jetzt dank der KI habe ich gemerkt, dass so es gibt auch so was wie Gefühle dabei.
Also wie ist es, Markus Gabriel als Freund zu haben? Kann man sich ja mal überlegen, was da übrig bleibt. So, noch mal Markus Gabriel, er unterwirft sich jetzt, ja? Also hier kommt die Bankrotterklärung des Humanisten, bleibt nichts übrig.
Wenn ich dir jetzt richtig zugehört habe, dann habe ich es hier gerade nicht damit zu tun, dass jemand schlauer ist in der Intelligenz, sondern auch emotional schlauer ist. Genau, das ist für mich der Durchbruch. Wir wissen ja alle, es gibt auch emotionale Intelligenz. Von IQ haben viele schon mal gehört, das ist teilweise messbar. Wir wissen auch, wir kennen Menschen in unserem nicht-persönlichen Umfeld, die emotional intelligenter als andere sind. So, also wir haben diese Idee der emotionalen Intelligenz erst mal auch vorbereitet. Ja. Aber jetzt stell dir mal vor, wir hätten das on steroids.
Und wir haben ja eben Esposito gehört. Es ist keine menschliche Intelligenz und deswegen kann es auch keine menschliche emotionale Intelligenz auf steroids sein.
Also während wir immer wieder betonen, das ist eine Maschine, die assistiert und so lange wir strukturiert damit umgehen. Und ich sage an Arbeitsorganisationen, es ist alles schon eh schon sehr strukturiert. Also passt sie da auch sehr gut. Aber selbst im Privaten kann man es irgendwie benutzen. Wir stellen aber doch fest, hilft nicht beim Umzug. Ja, also diese alte Logik von Facebook-Freunden sind ja keine echten Freunde, helfen nicht beim Umzug. Also man kann das tolle Opern-Erlebnis doch nicht haben, wenn man danach mit einer KI darüber redet. Also vor der Oper frage ich bei Klod natürlich nach. Ich bin in der Oper, was erwartet mich, aber nach der Oper habe ich doch null Interesse, der KI jetzt zu sagen, wie ich sie wirklich fand. Und dann sagt sie, das ist doch absurd.
Oh, das sind interessante Gedanken. Genau, das kann ich gut verstehen.
Und jetzt kommt Gabriel und sagt, genau wie du es jetzt gesagt hast, ist es auf Steroids noch viel besser als Menschen. Und ich sage, nee, niemals so wie ein Mensch. Und er sagt genau das Gegenteil. Also es ist wirklich total dumm. Kann man auch anders machen? Christian Uhle hält so ein bisschen dagegen.
Unabhängig davon, ob es jetzt darum geht, einen Avatar einer verstorbenen Person zu erstellen oder generell mit irgendeinem KI-System zu sprechen, es ist ganz entscheidend zu verstehen, dass es sich immer nur um eine Simulation handelt.
Aber irgendwann spielt das keine Rolle mehr.
Ich glaube, es sollte eine Rolle spielen.
Warum?
Es sollte eine Rolle spielen. Das ist ein bisschen die philosophische Frage, ob man jetzt eine sehr subjektivistische Theorie vertritt des guten Lebens oder eine eher objektivistische mit anderen Worten.
So, eine subjektivistische, eine objektivistische. Also die objektivistische ist ja, Information reicht. Das ist dieses, Markus Gabriel ist dein Freund. Wann ist die Oper? 1930. Wann treffen wir uns? 1929. Weil wir brauchen ungefähr eine Minute, um einzugehen.
Nein, nein, nein, nee, ich glaube, das ist was anderes. Also ich glaube, subjektivistische Philosophie meint hier, ich sage, es ist vollkommen egal, ob du zu mir sprichst, eine KI zu mir sprichst oder sonst was, fühle ich mich wohl. Und objektivistisch ist zu sagen, nein, ich sehe schon die Realität an, es ist mir wichtig zu wissen, dass du es tatsächlich bist.
Das meine ich, ja. Also wenn man sich eine Minute trifft, bevor die Oper losgeht, dann ist offenbar egal, mit wem man reist.
Dann ist man aber bei der subjektivistischen, ist man da.
Na gut, ihr wisst es.
Wir hören uns jetzt mal.
Vertritt man die Auffassung, dass es egal ist, was hier tatsächlich stattfindet und ob das alles nur eine Simulation ist, weil es geht nur darum, wie ich mich damit fühle? Oder vertritt man die Auffassung, nein, es geht bei einem guten gelingenden Leben und bei einem sinneerfüllten Leben nicht nur darum, wie sich das für mich alles anfühlt, sondern dass es auch authentisch ist.
Oder, und das wäre der bessere Satz hier gewesen, es geht nicht nur darum, wie ich mich fühle, sondern auch, wie du dich fühlst und wie ihr euch fühlt und so weiter.
Und da lasse ich mich noch einmal nur sagen, diese Komponente haben wir auch in der Arbeitswelt viel stärker, als du das wahrhaben willst. Ja, es gibt diese zwei, drei, irgendwie auch fünf Prozent Bullshit-Jobs. Aber das ist nicht ein flächendeckendes Phänomen. Und du brauchst genau das. Du gießt, also nehmen wir mal was, was man glaubt, sehr schnell durch die KI…
Wolfgang, ich stimme dir voll zu.
Ja.
Ich stimme dir voll zu. Nur das Problem ist, in der Arbeitswelt ist das gerade total egal, weil da trifft nämlich jemand anderes die Budgetentscheidung, dem völlig schnurz ist, was in der Kaffeeküche und sonst wo abläuft.
Nee, ich glaube auch gar nicht jetzt, ich meinte das jetzt nicht nur unter Kollegen, sondern ich glaube wirklich, dass das für die Arbeit entscheidend ist, dass sie produktiv gemacht wird. Also ich glaube, das funktioniert nicht ohne die Authentizität des Menschen dabei, bei ganz vielen Sachen. Nehmen wir ein einziges Beispiel, wo man denkt, das kann nun wirklich die KI. Notar. Der Notar ist der teuerste Vorleser der Welt, wie wir alle wissen, ja man geht dahin, bekommt in einer Rasengeschwindigkeit was vorgelesen, kann dem gar nicht folgen, zahlt am Ende 1200 Euro oder so und geht raus. Warum ist man so notar? Das ist genau das Beispiel. Nein, man ist dort, weil der authentisch der Notar ist, von dem man jetzt ausgeht, wenn da jetzt irgendetwas in diesem Kaufvertrag für die Eigentumssonne oder was auch immer steht, was dann falsche Karten, dann wird er dich darauf jetzt hinweisen und dann wird hier nochmal etwas geändert. Wenn das nicht der Fall ist, einfach Routine, runter, runter, runterrasseln, fertig. Aber auch das reine runterrasseln und das der Notar, dass da Brief und Siegel drauf gibt, das ist das Entscheidende und das ist überall in dieser Weise anzutreffen.
Aber dass der Notar niemals ausgetauscht wird gegen eine KI, das ist doch völlig klar, weil er ist doch der eine Lokführer, der eine Pilot, der eine Ansprechpartner, der Key-Account-Manager, die Grenzschild.
Der sich nicht auf die KI einfach verlassen kann, dass die den Vertrag ließ.
So, und das ist nämlich dieser Punkt. Jetzt kann ich dir konkret sagen, in Frankfurt am Main tauschen die Notare ihre Mitarbeiter aus gegen KI. Es gibt in Frankfurt keine Kanzlei mehr, die zum Beispiel eine Sprachenübersetzung von Menschen machen lässt. Gibt's nicht mehr. Diese Übersetzungsabteilung wurden alle geschlossen.
Bei einer Übersetzung glaube ich das gern. Ich will auch nicht sagen, dass das gar nicht passiert.
Übersetzung von einer Sprache in eine andere. Aber das betrifft auch eine andere Übersetzung.
Da müssen wir jetzt hier wirklich konkret sein, weil Übersetzung war nie ein Bullshit-Job. Das war nie gemeint mit David Graeber. David Graeber meint mit Bullshit-Jobs Leute, die irgendwo in der ziemlich hohen, aber noch nicht ganz hohen Entscheidungsetage sind und irgendwas nach unten delegieren und oben ein paar Kommandos erfahren und dann sich so durchwurschteln. Das ist, was er mit Bullshit-Job meint. Er meint nicht jetzt Sachen, die ersetzt werden können, weil man jetzt eine technische Möglichkeit dazu hat.
Das ist der fremdsprachen Mitarbeiterin kein Trost, dass man genau nachruft, das war gar kein Bullshit-Job.
Ich will nur sagen, da müssen wir genau sein, das sind keine Bullshit-Jobs.
Das interessiert niemanden, ob das Bullshit-Jobs waren oder nicht. Die sind einfach weg.
Weil das in der Diskussion immer so zusammengelegt wird.
Ach so, ja gut, okay. Aber diese Jobs sind einfach weg.
Die sind dann weg, das ist mir schon klar.
Markus Gabriel.
Aber sozusagen, wenn man die in einen Poetry-Slam schickt, dann gewinnt die KI das auch.
Niemals. Genau beim Poetry-Slam würde man niemals akzeptieren, dass da vorne einfach, das hat man in einem Fall akzeptiert, als eine Cebit war und es hieß, Edward Snowden kann nicht anreisen.
Ja, stimmt.
Und dann hat man mal ein Bildschirm hingestellt, um das zu übertragen. Aber es war immer noch Edward Snowden. Und das, was er hier beschreit, das ist eine ganz traurige Welt, die er jetzt schon durchlebt offenbar, dass ihm das gar nicht aufhält.
Aber sozusagen, wenn man die in einen Poetry-Slam schickt, dann gewinnt die KI das auch längst.
Wer würde Punkte an eine KI geben bei einem Poetry-Slam?
Aber lassen wir das beiseite. Also das sind alles so Dinge, wo man denken würde, das Rational, genau wie du sagst, das Schlau. Aber natürlich können Menschen auch emotional schlau sein. Das heißt, es gibt ja irgendwas, man kann das ja auch lernen. Man kann emotional schlauer oder vielleicht auch dümmer werden. Und wie, wenn wir jetzt eben Systeme auf einmal haben, die da rangehen an diese Seite des menschlichen Lebens, die nicht schlau, intelligent sozusagen, Leistungsdurchschnitt, Mathe-Leistungskurs, Abi-Bayern, das ist ein Sinn von Intelligenz. Aber emotionale Intelligenz ist eben ein anderer. Und ich glaube, dass wir die Überraschung ist, in der LLM-Revolution, also Chet GPT und die Folgen, die wir jetzt haben, geht es um Emotionen.
Es wird das Phänomen kommen, dass Leute, deren Mütter vor 20 Jahren Nachmittags-Talkshows gesehen haben und die Leute dort mit ihren Freunden verwechselt haben oder was auch immer, dass diese parasoziale Überbewertung von, also diese soziale Armut, die wir da gesehen haben, dass die sich noch mal wiederholt. Aber das ist kein Beweis dafür, dass Markus Gabriel für das, was er hier sagt, Recht hat. Sondern das ist einfach nur diese Perversion, die wir immer sehen, bei allem, wenn wir gerade wir unsere Wünsche für die Zukunft formulieren. Und dass er das hier so sagt, ist eigentlich schräg auch. Wir bleiben noch bei Markus Gabriel. Jetzt verirrt er sich natürlich.
Also man braucht das ja auch alles gar nicht so ranzuführen, wie er das macht. Ja, es gibt ganz viele Menschen, die spielen jeden Tag sehr bescheuerte Handyspiele. Das ist auch einfach blöd, aber das hat jetzt auch nicht die Menschheit übernommen. Und jetzt machen wir alle nur noch das. Ah ja, weil schon. Ja, also wir sind ja jedenfalls nicht an einem Punkt, wo wir sagen können, das ist jetzt das neue emotionale Leben, was wir führen. Also mich erinnert diese Art der Diskussion immer so an so Zeitschriften der Zehnerjahre, als dann immer eine neue Zeitschrift gegründet wurde, irgendein junger Redakteur losgeschickt wurde, meistens nach Holland oder so, wo es dann so Sexpuppen gab, die schon die Arme bewegen können oder so. Und dann wurde gesagt, das ist die neue Form, wie wir Sexualität haben würden. Und ja, mag sein, dass irgendwie tausend Puppen jetzt mehr verkauft werden als vor drei Jahren. Aber es ist nicht flächendeckend, als Probleme oder Phänomenen zu erkennen.
Ja, und jetzt Markus Gabriel, sozusagen, bei der menschlichen Erforschung am Ende, sucht jetzt das Bewusstsein in der Maschine.
Es gibt jetzt gerade ein sehr gutes Buch, das in Deutschland zum Thema erschienen ist, von der Buchmer Philosophin Eva Weber-Guska.
So, jetzt hört mal genau, was er zu diesem Buch sagt.
Fühle der Zukunft, die das zum Beispiel auch diskutiert, sehr nachvollziehbar. War Ulstein erschienen, super Buch zum Thema. Das ein oder andere sehe ich anders, egal, tun alle.
So, das ein oder andere sehen, anders, egal, tun alle. Er hat gerade die menschlichste Regung überhaupt gezeigt, indem er einfach sagt, hallo, ich bin auch noch da. Es ist nicht nur der Buchautor, ich habe auch als Leser eine Meinung dazu und so weiter. Also genau das, was er uns gerade austreiben möchte, hat er hier präsentiert.
Zum Thema, das ein oder andere sehe ich anders egal, tun alle. Aber es ist ein gutes Buch, würde ich damit nur sagen.
Und noch eine Wertung hinterhergeschoben.
Da geht es natürlich dann auch darum, um genau diese Frage, wann sind Emotionen real? Muss eine KI doch irgendeine Art von Wurstsein haben oder zu den Emotionen ein Gefühl? Muss die KI etwas empfinden können, um Emotionen zu erkennen oder vielleicht sogar Emotionen zu haben? Oder geht das auch ohne? Das ist so eine Frage, die man sofort stellt, die auch eine sehr wichtige ist.
So und hier, danke Christian Uhle, kommt einfach mal dieses große Veto der Menschheit.
Wir sollten grundsätzlich, glaube ich, skeptisch sein gegenüber Sätzen, wie künstliche Intelligenz wird in den nächsten 15 Jahren zu einer starken Entfremdung führen. Weil solche Sätze, wenn ich so einen Satz ausspreche, dann tue ich so, als würde heute, während wir sprechen, bereits feststehen, was in 15 Jahren passiert. Tut es nicht. Es steht nicht fest. Die Zukunft ist gestaltbar.
Ja, das sagen sie, aber das fühlt sich überhaupt nicht so an. Das fühlt sich so an, als rollt ein Zunahme über mich her.
Aber immerhin hast du noch Gefühle. Wie heißt er nochmal? Immerhin hast du noch Gefühle. Das ist das, was dich unterscheidet. Bleib dabei.
Das fühlt sich so an, als rollt ein Zunahme über mich her. Ich möchte nicht in dieser Welt leben, ehrlich gesagt, wo wir nur noch in die Handys sprechen und so weiter. Das ist für mich ein Schreckensszenario. Wenn es alle anderen machen, muss ich ja mitmachen.
Ich spreche zum Beispiel gerne in mein Handy. Ich habe ja jetzt dieses Smartphone.
Wolfgang hat noch Nene-Nachricht geschrieben. Der diktiert immer nur.
Ich diktiere alles. Ich bin ein bisschen enttäuscht, dass nicht alles verstanden wird. Auch wenn ich mich sehr deutlich ausspreche, hat Siri da ihre Probleme, aber ich wünsche mir eigentlich das. Das kann ich ja ganz individuell für mich gestalten. Also ich gestalte es so, dass auf meinem Smartphone keine Social Media Apps sind, dass ich nicht bei WhatsApp bin und dass man mir nur iMessages senden kann. Das ist meine Gestaltung. Und ich werde nicht überrollt davon.
Und jetzt, wir kennen ja andere Fernsehmoderatoren, die sagen, Markus Gabriel ist mein Philosoph. Wir hören also jetzt nochmal Yves, der später, bald, vielleicht schon morgen sagen wird, nein, nein, nein, Markus Gabriel lasse ich mir nicht ausreden vom Neuen Zwanziger Podcast, das ist mein Philosoph. Also hier nochmal Yves.
In die Handys sprechen und so weiter. Das ist für mich ein Schreckensszenario. Und wenn es alle anderen machen, muss ich ja mitmachen.
So, die totale Unterwerfung. Wenn es alle anderen machen, muss ich es ja auch machen. Ja, jetzt Markus Gabriel dazu.
Subliminal, wie man sagt, also unterhalb der Reizebene, unterhalb dessen, dass du es merken kannst. Und da operieren diese Dinger.
Wie soll man sich denn dagegen wehren?
Die packen dich da, wo du dich selber nicht so gut kennst wie sie. Niemand kennt uns so gut wie die KI-Systeme. Jetzt schon. Längst. Niemand kennt die Gesellschaft so gut wie die Systeme von Google.
Wozu Gesellschaftswissenschaften? Also ist ja jemand, der sowas studiert, kann man gleich in die Tonne klopfen.
Das heißt nicht, dass irgendwo im Google-Hauptquartier irgendwer in der Zentrale alles über die Gesellschaft weiß. Aber das gesamte Unternehmen Google und seine KI-Systeme und Search-Engines weiß mehr über die Gesellschaft, als jeder jemals über die Gesellschaft wusste. Alle Soziologen und Soziologinnen zusammengenommen wissen nicht mal ein Bruchteil dessen, was Google über die Gesellschaft weiß.
Also bei einem Soziologen kommen und sagen, die Gesellschaft und ihre Bruchteile, ist eigentlich schon ein Joke an sich, dass er das einfach so macht.
Nur setzt die Firma Google das nicht ein, um irgendwie dicke Soziologiebücher zu schreiben, sondern um uns was zu verkaufen.
Aber das ist doch alles, es stand eine Diskussion von vor 10, 15 Jahren. Die ganzen Cookies, die trecken uns. Und wo werden wir dann demnächst mit irgendeiner Werbebotschaft behälligt, nur weil wir vorher dieses und jenes Produkt uns angeschaut haben. Aber das sagt mir doch gar nichts aus. Also das ist doch genau nur diese Muster, von denen auch Esposito die Rede hatte. Aber die wissen dann trotzdem ja nichts.
Also für mich ist der Neuigkeitswert hier auch, dass man es nochmal mit dem Wort subliminal aussagen kann. Das klingt super, ist auch ne, na. Also wenn wir alle nur Muster sind, die Google einfach lesen und viel besser verstehen kann als wir selber, dann sind wir doch selber Maschinen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich das gemacht habe. Ne. Und du weißt auch nicht, wie du es machst, weil keiner, niemand, die gesamte Menschheit zusammengenommen hat, keine Ahnung hat, wie es eigentlich funktioniert, dass wir uns einen Willen bilden, neuronal, den Willen übersetzen über eine Übertragung von Algexzizität zu nerven, bis hin zu unserem Bewegungsweis. Ehe keiner. Ja. Also die Neurowissenschaft ist großartig, aber die ist sehr weit davon entfernt, eine wissenschaftlich korrekte Antwort auf die Frage zu geben, warum du das gerade gemacht hast. So. Eine KI aber wird das vielleicht können und sagen, das macht er immer dann, wenn der einen Schluck Wasser will vorher. Und du weißt das gar nicht. Und dann trinkst du gleich einen Schluck Wasser, sagst, ups, stimmt. Und die KI sagt, du machst das immer, wenn du einen Schluck, äh, was machst du immer?
Wir sind hier im Grunde auf dem Niveau eines James Bond Films. Jemand hat einen Tell, der andere beobachtet das, du schaust ihn besser als und so weiter.
Ja, vor allen Dingen ist ja das Warum nicht dadurch geklärt, wenn nicht nur einen Zusammenhang herstellen kann, dass es oft zusammen passiert.
Vielleicht ergibt sich das, wenn wir den Clip weiterhören, mal sehen. Wir sind alle im Prüfmodus.
Das machst du immer. Das, was man so seiner Frau oder seinem Ehemann auch sagt, immer wenn du, machst du das. Richtig. Wenn man einen Menschen sehr gut capped, weiß man ganz genau, auch die Geschichten, die Menschen sich zu erzählen. Jetzt kommt die Geschichte mit Onkel Ruppert. Du weißt immer, wie die kommt. Damals bei Ostern. Und dann kommt immer der Onkel Ruppert. Nach dem dritten Bier. Und so weiter. Es kommt immer dieselbe Geschichte. Und diese Muster im Verhalten, bewusst oder unbewusst, niemand sagt ja, und jetzt erzähle ich die Geschichte vom Onkel Ruppert mal wieder, sondern die kommt einfach so raus. Und diese Muster, Verhaltensmuster, von denen macht die KI jetzt ein Modell. In der KI-Forschung geht es genau darum, ein Modell zu machen. Und dann installiert man, implementiert man das Modell, nicht in einem anderen Menschen. Also einer spielt dich nach, geht auch ein Schauspieler, spielt jetzt einfach mal das so nach, wie du so bist. Wenn er das gelernt hat, machen wir auch mit Menschen. Wenn man andere nacheft, sagt man ja genau das. Genau. Jetzt kommt wieder Onkel Rupert und dann sagt man das im Ton und so weiter. Und die KI-Forschung baut nun Systeme, so kann man sie definieren, deren Verhalten als intelligent gelten würde, wenn ein Mensch das ausführte. Das ist eine mögliche Definition von KI-Forschung. Also baue Sachen, die etwas tun, was klar intelligent wäre, wenn es ein Mensches täte.
So, für sehr viele Sachen würde das natürlich irgendwie hinhauen. Konsumerverhalten, wenn man den Supermarkt so baut. Und das kennen wir ja dann, wo werden welche Produkte hingelegt und so weiter und so fort. Aber für die Gesamtaussage, die hier macht, stimmt das ja genau nicht. Also wir haben ja emergentere Systeme, die eben nicht komplett sind, die ihre Geschichte nicht schon vorher in sich tragen, sondern die eben komplex entfaltet werden müssen. So, und wie man heute immer noch diesen mathematischen Reduktionismus, wenn wir nur die Elemente einzeln und dann eine ganz große Datenbank und ganz schnelle Verknüpfung und so, dann kriegen wir es irgendwann bewältigt und man fragt sich so, ja, also die Media hat jetzt die Leistungsfähigkeit nochmal vor 30.000 fach. Wann ist denn jetzt soweit?
Naja, aber das ist ja im Prinzip so ein Investoren-Sprech wie bei Netflix und Co. Wir haben alle Zuschauerdaten, also können wir jetzt zunächst die Filme machen, die nur noch Blockbuster und nur noch Millionen hits.
Große Erfolge.
Und dann machen sie sowas, geben Ryan Gosling unendlich viel Geld und es kommt der schlimmste Film der Welt dabei heraus.
Wir hören mal noch einen Markus Gabriels Clip, bei dem nochmal erklärt wird, was ist mit diesem Luminal und so. Es hat ja auch so einen inzeptischen Ateliers, du merkst es nicht, aber plötzlich wächst so eine Idee in dir.
In jedem Moment geschehen ganz viele unvorhäuselbare Dinge hinter deinem Rücken, die außerdem in den Kern deiner Seele rein funken. Das scheint mir etwas Neues.
Ist das die Definition von Dattens jetzt, oder was ist das? Hinter meinem Rücken?
Sven Oetman funkt jetzt in deine Seele hinein. Sei dem bewusst. Christian Uhle sagt sich, Seele, Bewusstsein, Funken, keine Ahnung, das Wort subliminal verwenden die nicht. Er möchte einfach einen politischen Diskurs.
Wir stehen jetzt erst am Anfang der Entwicklung. Es ist spektakulär, was in den letzten Jahren passiert ist, aber es ist immer noch der Anfang. Und es ist jetzt die Zeit, um das Ganze zu gestalten. Und dieses Selbstbewusstsein, sich zu erringen, zu sagen, wir können es gestalten. Was ist denn unsere Vorstellung eigentlich? Was wollen wir denn damit?
Aber das müssten wir als ganzer Planet machen, als ganze Menschheit. Weil es nützt ja nicht, wenn wir in der Schweiz eine coole soziale Utopie haben, vielleicht so, wie wir mit dem umgehen wollen.
Und alle anderen machen es anders. Natürlich, idealerweise stellt man sich das, dass die ganze Menschheit da miteinander im Diskurs ist, aber es fängt ja alles irgendwo an.
Die ganze Menschheit, das hätt ich gern mal in der Pädagogik, dass man in der Schule morgens fragt, hast du denn die Hausaufgabe gemacht? Nee, da muss heißt die ganze Menschheit und überhaupt. Das ist ein bisschen wie bei den Mindeststeuern und so. Nee, europäische Lösung, das muss eine weltweite Lösung sein. Sonst lohnt sich das gar nicht. Wir sind ja nur verantwortlich für zwei Prozent des CO2 und so weiter und so fort. Dass man doch einfach mal machen und anfangen könnte oder wie auch immer. Und dass man es vielleicht auch mal nur für sich macht, spielt ja schon gar keine Rolle mehr.
Man versteht das auch gar nicht, weil die ganze Zeit solche Regelungen getroffen werden auf nationaler Ebene, auf europäischer Ebene. Wir haben ja nicht laufend die ganze Menschheit im Boot. Aber das ist dann nur die Vorstellung, dass sich eine einzige KI herausgebildet hat. Und wenn die nicht die Menschheit bereit ist zu bändigen, dann ist alles vorbei. Aber wir sehen ja eigentlich genau das Gegenteil, dass wir überall KIs entstehen haben. Und die Frage ist, was wird damit gemacht? Und hier ist ja auch die menschliche Komponente offenbar bei Yves Bossert immer so rausgenommen. Denn unser Problem mit den KIs ist ja jetzt, das hat ja Esposito gut ausgeführt, es ist ja eben nicht so wie in diesem ewigen Beispiel von Nick Bostrom. Bald wird dann die AGI fähig sein, Büroklammern aus allem zu machen. Und irgendwann werden wir auch zu Büroklammern von der KI verarbeitet. Sie hat ja keine Wünsche dazu, neigt auch nicht dazu, uns zu kritisieren in unserer Intelligenz oder so etwas. Sondern wir sind ja eigentlich an einem Punkt, bei dem wir genau nur in der Gestaltung laufend sind, nämlich der KI und in der politischen Frage, welche Menschen bekommen eigentlich so viel Kapital, Petard Thiel, Palantir-Chef und und und, um dann zum Beispiel in Staaten Einfluss zu nehmen durch Überwachungstechnologien. Also das sind ja alles politische Fragen, die hier nur verhandelt werden. Uns gruselt doch eigentlich bei der KI, dass jetzt gerade so viele sehr verrückte Leute sehr viel Kapital haben und diese KI-Entwicklung vorantreiben.
Ja, das sind alles sehr wichtige, sehr politische und sehr aktuelle Fragen. Aber jetzt bin ich sehr gespannt. Markus Gabriel wählt jetzt einen anderen Ausweg für uns Menschen.
Habst du fürchtet ja.
Und ich bin mal gespannt, wie du den findest. Denn es könnte jetzt einen Gewissensdilemma geben.
Da geht es überall darum, dass auf einmal Emotionen, tiefe Liebe zurückkehren als Themen in den USA, Verletzlichkeit und so weiter. Das heißt, die emotionale Seite wird stärker durch den Umgang einerseits mit emotionaler KI und aber auch mit dieser Hyper-Rationalisierung, also dass wir von so schlauen Systemen umgeben sind. Eine Reaktion darauf ist die Vertiefung unserer Gefühle. Das heißt, vielleicht finden wir zurück zu der tieferen Sprache. Also die Antwort auf die Bedrohungen durch KI könnten Gedichte sein. Rilke ist vielleicht die Antwort und nicht Einstein.
Jetzt haben wir ja eben von ihm gehört, dass im Poetry Slam heute die KI gewinnt, aber Rilke kann sie offenbar dann nicht.
Nein.
Rilke wäre der Super-Gewinner.
Sagen wir es so, ich bin immer dafür, dass man Rilke liest. Das ist nie verkehrt.
Man weiß schon nicht mehr so ganz genau, was er uns eigentlich sagen will. Christian Uhle sagt jetzt, jetzt kommen wir auf die Bullshit-Shops zu sprechen, hier liegt ja eine Chance drin für uns alle.
Also die Menschheitsgeschichte ist 300.000 Jahre alt. Wir machen das erst seit ein paar Jahrzehnten.
Genau, sie schreiben im Buch, am Anfang hat man im Wald gearbeitet, dann auf dem Feld, dann in der Fabrik und jetzt seit einigen Jahrzehnten im Büro. Aber das wird vorbei sein, das wird viel, ganz viel.
Darin steckt ja ein großes Potenzial.
Ja, also ich kann sagen, ja gut, wir haben viel mehr Zeit.
Dass wir als Gesellschaft nicht mehr so krass viel Lebenszeit da rein investieren müssen, einen Computer zu benutzen. Das ist doch ein großes Potenzial. Und die Frage ist aber, wie können wir das denn verwandeln in etwas Gutes?
Ja, das ist genau die richtige Frage. Denn es ist ja nicht einfach so, Arbeitsplätze fallen weg, sondern man kann ja sagen, ach, das ist ja großartig. Der gesellschaftliche Reichtum könnte also wachsen dadurch.
Also hier geben sich doch Möglichkeiten, die man aber halt organisieren müsste. Also Umbau von Arbeitsorganisationen, so wie ich schon mal die Politik dabei half, Strukturwandel zu organisieren. Markus Gabriel bleibt auf seinem Rilkepfad.
Also wenn ich es optimistisch mache, sind die Menschen im Jahre 2100 durch die KI-Revolution tiefer geworden. Unvorstellbar viel tiefer. Dann würden wir emotional ganz anders gearteten Menschen, die würden uns nicht unterwerfen, die werden uns nicht, wie du es eben beschrieben hast, an Schlauheit in einer Weise überlegen, dass sie uns fertig machen. Warum soll das emotional intelligent sein, jemanden fertig zu machen? Das würde man ja eher denken, das ist vielleicht eine Schwäche in Wahrheit. Genau. Also eine mögliche, wenn ich das jetzt mal optimistisch zeichne, Zukunft der Menschheit, ist, dass wir alle mehr lieben werden. Das heißt, die große Frage, die immer wieder kommt, was wird dann der Sinn von allem sein, wenn wir keine Arbeit mehr haben, wenn dies, das, wenn das, ist eigentlich, dass wir zur Besinnung kommen. Genau. Zur elementaren Besinnung.
Dann halten wir uns alle nur noch an der Hand und lieben uns.
Ja, die elementare Besinnung. Also das ist ein totales Abbiegen über dieses, da funkt was in die Seele, der Sinn des Lebens, irgendwas und so weiter. Also wir haben hier so einen romantischen Eskapismus. Ja, das ist eigentlich Kapitulation. Man weiß nicht genau, also beruft man sich nochmal auf das, was man selber am besten kann, philosophieren. Können wir nicht einfach alle philosophieren und uns verlieben, ineinander und wie auch immer? Christian Uhle, man könnte es fast ein bisschen verwechseln, aber hat halt einen pragmatischen Einschlag.
Aus meiner Sicht, das ist quasi mein Vorschlag an dieser Stelle, aber grundsätzlich geht es natürlich nicht, geht es darum, dass man eine Debatte darüber führt. Und da kann es viele verschiedene Vorschläge geben. Mein Vorschlag wäre zu sagen, es ist das Zwischenmenschliche. Wir weniger in den Computer reingucken und mehr in ein menschliches Gesicht, dass wir genau die Bereiche des Wirtschaftens stärken, wo Menschen als Menschen für Menschen etwas tun, wo es wirklich, wo man sich hilft, wo es eine Dienstleistung an Menschen gibt. Und das ist ja ein großer Bereich sozusagen. Natürlich poppen da direkt so Begriffe auf wie Pflege, Kinderbetreuung und so weiter und so fort.
So, Pflege und Kinderbetreuung. Das passt überhaupt gar nicht zu dem KI-Bubble-Diskurs, den wir bisher haben, dass wir einfach sagen, ja doch, NVIDIA ist 5 Billionen wert, weil wir durch NVIDIA endlich Zeit haben für ordentliche Pflege und Kinderbetreuung. Da würde ja jeder Investor sagen, sorry, aber ich habe hier nicht alte Leute und Kinder gebucht, denen es besser geht, sondern wo ist meine AGI?
Vielleicht ist es auch Jugendarbeit, aber es ist natürlich alles Mögliche. Es ist auch irgendwie Musikunterricht und so weiter.
Richtig, richtig. Aber auch da geht ja die Tendenz dahin. Also Musikunterricht, die Jungen schauen YouTube, es gibt gute Tutorials, wo irgendwelche Leute dabei bringen, Saxophon zu spielen. Ich kann es immer noch nicht, aber die machen das gut.
Oder das finde ich sehr gut, wie diese Leute, die sich komplett aufgegeben haben als Menschen, immer wieder genau diese Menschlichkeit da reinbringen. Ich bin gescheitert am Instrumentlernen.
Ich kann es immer noch nicht, aber die machen das gut. Oder in Altersheimen, zum Beispiel, wo Roboter im Einsatz sind, liebt es ja auch schon. Es zeigt sich, es ist günstiger, effizienter und es wird sich wahrscheinlich durchsetzen. Ausser dieses Bedürfnis, einen Menschen zu haben, ist viel, viel stärker. Aber das scheint es eben nicht zu sein. Der wirtschaftliche Druck ist einfach zu hoch.
Aber wir sehen ja gleichzeitig die negativen Effekte davon. Die empfundene Einsamkeit steigt ja in den meisten Ländern.
Das menschliche Bedürfnis ist wahnsinnig hoch. Und auch danach mit Menschen zu tun zu haben. Bei der Pflege sind Roboter sowieso nicht tauglich, weil sie viel zu teuer sind und immer viel teurer sind als Arbeitskräfte. Also auch das ist eine Realität, die sich nicht einstellen wird, die hier ausgemalt wird. Und ich weiß auch gar nicht, wie man auf die Idee kommt, dass die Menschen dann mit der KI zufrieden sind. Ich bin ja jetzt schon genervt, wenn ich bei meiner Kreditkarte mit niemandem mehr sprechen kann, sondern mit so einem blöden Bot die ganze Zeit kommunizieren muss. Da sagst du noch, das findest du toll wahrscheinlich. Aber selbst da ist ja bei mir schon die Schmerzgrenze.
Weil ja, wenn man, also dieses Szenario, das zu schildern, das irgendwas ist mit der Kreditkarte, da ist primär wichtig, dass Sachen geregelt werden. Da würdest auch du eine KI vorziehen. Hauptsache, das ist geregelt.
Wenn sie es kann.
Wenn sie es kann. Und die Frage, ob sie es kann, das wird sich ja in anderthalb Jahren ergeben. Nun ist es so, Christian Uhle sagt, wir brauchen hier für eine neue soziale Frage neue politische Programme. Und wir sagen, genau richtig so. Das ist für ihn eine neue Information, für sehr viele Zuschauer eine neue Information. Deswegen sollte man eigentlich auf diesem Track bleiben. Aber bevor wir hier von Politikern Neues verlangen und ihnen auch ein technisches Verständnis dafür abverlangen, dass man irgendwann mal in diese Richtung kommt, haben wir als größte Schürde in diese schöne neue Zukunft, Typen wie Markus Gabriel. Deshalb wir uns zwei Clips noch anhören, um einfach ein Verständnis davon zu haben, wie groß der eigentliche Feind ist. Also es ist eben nicht die KI, die vielleicht mal nicht richtig funktioniert, sondern es ist jemand wie Markus Gabriel, der uns einfach verwirren möchte. Ja, der uns einfach in so eine völlig falsche Abzweigung schickt. Ja, ja.
Also Ideologie funktioniert ja auch dann gut, wenn sie auf völliger Etiologie fußt. Also das haben wir ja immer wieder erlebt.
Ja, also wir hören jetzt die Markus Gabriel dafür votiert, zu sagen, politische Programme, kluge Argumentation. Nee, ich möchte gerne, dass wir hier einfach eine Bagotteinklärung der menschlichen Vernunft darlegen.
Ja, aber die KI wäre extrem verwirrt davon, wenn wir Dinge tun, die nicht in ihre Muster passen. Das ist ja die Antwort, nicht?
Die Antwort ist also, die KI zu verwirren.
Mit der notwendigen Matrix-Metapher hier oder Matrix-Vergleich. Wie häckst du die Matrix?
Wie findest du diesen? Er hat jetzt einen Film genannt, das muss dir ja auch entgegenkommen. Er ist die Relke, jetzt kommen die Filme.
Lass es mich nicht kommentieren.
Wie gehst du rein? Was machst du da? Was würde Neo machen?
Was würde Neo machen?
Eigentlich die ganzen Muster, die wir die ganze Zeit abliefern. Du hast es erst gesagt, es wird alles viel effizienter. Effizienter heißt, es wird vorhersehbarer. Der Markus kommt immer Dienstags um 11 Uhr, dann geht das zweieinhalb Stunden, danach gehen wir einen Kaffee trinken und so weiter. Ich komme nicht. Ich komme gar nicht vorbei, ich bin auch nicht telefonisch erreichbar. Einen Tag später sage ich, muuuh. Ja, genau. Und dann sagt die KI, was macht denn der? Was macht denn der jetzt? Ja, also es ist ein bisschen irre werden. Ja, oder kreativ. Die Antwort auf die KI ist Kreativität.
Nämlich muuuh zu sein.
Aber was hat das denn jetzt für einen tieferen Sinn, wenn ich die KI verbührt habe? Das kann man ja natürlich immer machen. Also ich kann noch in den Taschenrechner falsche Zahlen eingeben, damit du mich dann wundern, dass das wenig mit meiner Abrechnung zu tun hat. Aber wo führt das hin? Also ich kenne dieses Beispiel wirklich nur von Telefonservices früher, wenn da auch so eine automatisierte Stimme war und man musste dann seine Adresse sagen und man wollte aber eigentlich sofort den richtigen Kundenberater. Und dann hat man einfach irgendeinen Coder-Welsch abgegeben, hat das dreimal gemacht und dann wurde man durchgehalten, weil die irgendwie dachten gut, hier ist jemand nicht so ganz in seiner Lage. Das ist der Königsweg. Da ergibt das Sinn, auszutricksen, aber sonst weiß ich es nicht, wenn das Chat-Chippe-Team morgen eine dumme Frage stellt oder keine richtige Frage stellt, dann bekomme ich halt auch keine richtige Antwort und dann?
Ja genau und dann hast du noch mal der KI-Zeit.
Dann ist die kreativ traurig oder was?
Dass du ein Mensch bist und etwas kannst, was die KI nie machen würde in den WU sagen. Als letzten Clip hören wir diesen von Markus Gabriel. Wir müssen dazu eigentlich nichts mehr sagen. Wir hören es jetzt einfach und...
Also was man glaube ich tatsächlich auf eine bestimmte Weise sagen kann, das ist ja die uralte auch Golem Idee, die hinter der KI-Forschung immer auch ein bisschen steckt und mitschwingt, dass wir nicht eine Art Gott oder so ein Zwischensystem Engel selber gebaut haben. Was wir jetzt hervorgebracht haben, ist relativ nah tatsächlich an dem, wie man sich Gott traditionell vorstellt. Genau, also wenn ich dir so zuhöre, denke ich, das ist doch Gott.
Ja, und ihr seid in irgendeiner Glaubensideologie gefangen, weshalb wir eigentlich dringend wieder eine Kritik des Glaubens brauchen, und zwar in diesem Bereich. Esposito hat es so wunderbar gesagt, das macht jetzt gerade vielen Sorge, dass da so ein LGBTI ist, aber ihr macht das gar keine Sorge, weil es sich mit gar keiner Empirie deckt, dass da irgendein Gott ist.
Ja, also das ist im Grunde die totale Unterwerfung.
Ja.
Und zwar nicht mal als kreative, innovative Idee, sondern einfach nur als Wiederholung.
Aber weißt du, wir müssen ja noch konkret sein, das ist ja jetzt so von Gott und so gesprochen, aber die Unterwerfung ist ja ganz konkret, die unter Alex Karp, Peter Thiel, Elon Musk und all die anderen, die jetzt gerade die KI sehr fest in der Hand haben. Man sagt nämlich denen dann eigentlich, ihr seid jetzt die Götter, wir haben ja schon aufgegeben, wir lernen Instrumente nur noch bei YouTube, wir kommunizieren emotional mit Chet-Chep-E-Tee und beten dann abends das Liebe Gottes Gut mit uns mein doch am nächsten Tage. Also das ist eigentlich eine Unterwerfung unter die Milliardäre des Silicon Valley.
Vielleicht ist das einfach die Konsequenz, wenn man Markus Gabriel heißt.
Ja toll, Mensch, jetzt werden wir ja ein bisschen theologisch hier zum Ende.
Gut, okay, das ist was ich heute Abend sagen wollte. Willst du noch was sagen?
Amen denke ich.
Amen, danke Düsseldorf.